chairman thank you thank you
Tara good evening and welcome to this
District planning committee meeting on
Tuesday the 23st of January
2024 my name is councelor Kevin lagen
and I am the chairman of this committee
members we're steving this meeting live
as well as recording and by um and by
being present in the meeting you're
giving your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I'll
then invite you at the appropr time it
may not be in the order of which your
hand is raised depends on how we see
members um we'll do our best though
please note that the YouTube live stream
recording is dependent on the correct
use of microphones therefore can I ask
that when invited to speak you remember
to turn on your microphone and turn it
off when finished please reference a
page or paragraph number when referring
to agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
welcome and I'd like to welcome
everybody uh in The Gallery at the at
the rear of the chamber and those
watching on on live stream uh before we
move on to item number two uh councilor
labor has approached me uh wishes to
make a statement to the chamber so
councilor labor
please thank you um chairman I'd like to
make a brief statement it's been brought
to my attention that statements I made
during the debate of a planning
application in mland heard before this
committee on the 6th of September 2023
and an earlier meeting of the southeast
area planning committee on the 26th of
June 2023 callus defense to specific
planning off officers and planning
enforcement officers involved in
advising the local planning Authority on
learning of this concern I would like to
advise the committee that I met with the
assistant director of planning and
implementation who explained how my
comments had caused offense through the
questioning of officers professionalism
and the discharge of their duties in
respects of my comments and on
reflection of listening back to the
debate myself I accept that my choice of
words and tone concerning officer's
General approach to a specific planning
enforcement case and the advice in the
officers report that set out the review
of the merits of the planning
application were not fair whilst I am
not seeking to make excuses as a newly
elected member at the time of the
meetings in question I was still finding
my way through how to approach and
engage in planning committee debates
whilst also learning about how the
council works I would therefore like to
make it clear for the public record that
I have respect for the council's
officers to act diligently in the
discharge of their professional duties
and it was never my intention to cause
distress to them and I offer my sincere
apologies for having done so Council
thank you very very much indeed for that
it's very clear members final notice
from me I'm suspending um rule 4 section
8 subsection 3 the requirement to stand
when addressing the chair is totally up
to you if you wish to do so thank you
move on to uh agenda item number two
which is apologies for absence Tara
could we have apologies for absence
please yes chairman thank you apologies
that we received from councelor Hughes
councelor Miller councelor Sid and
councelor sils thank you chairman thank
you very much inde Clark thank you
councelor Morin yeah councelor Durham
also as his apologies as long as way
back from number 10 D did you uh catch
that Tara counc Dar councelor daram as
well AP thank you thank you very much
indeed we move on to uh agenda item
three which is the minutes uh which is
the minutes of the last meeting pH found
on pages 7 to 10 um of your agenda pack
this is to confirm the minutes of the
meeting of the district planning
committee held on the 6th of September
2023 copy closed it's recommended the
minutes are approved as a true and
accurate record I so move do I have a
second for that motion thank you very
much indeed councelor prep uh any points
or any comments to make members so take
that by Ascent agreed agreed thank you
members agenda item four which is
Declarations of Interest this is to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and non-real
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
9 and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members members are reminded that
they should also be required to disclose
any such interest as soon as they become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meeting members do have any
declarations
please tar there are
none so we move on to thank you very
much agenda item five which is a
reference
2387 FM this is land Southwest of Warren
Hackman's Lane pearly and it's p found
on pages 11 to 46 and members note that
there was a member update uh released
earlier on okay this report is going to
be presented by Miss Matthews Miss
Matthews please present the item thank
you chairman good evening members um
there's one further um update to mention
is that there was um an error in the
information that's submitted with the
application and the um the amount of
electricity this s of farm would produce
would power approximately 5,200 hones
per year and you also offset
approximately four 4,500 tons of CO2 per
year which is different to what is in
the papers thank you so this is a full
planning application um for the erection
of a solar farm together with a
substation ancillary building structures
Landscaping emergency lighting and
access development will be in place for
a period of 40 years following this the
land will be put back to its current
state this is the location plan the site
measures approximately 33 hectares the
majority of the site is located in the
molden district but but um some of the
site or the majority the proposed access
Falls within the administrative area of
chelsford city council the blue purple
line on the plan denotes the district
boundaries chumford have devolved their
powers to Moren District Council to
determine the application on their
behalf as the largest part of the
application site Falls within the
district one Council making the decision
on behalf of both authorities prevents
there being two different decisions
being made on on one application
removing the risk of there being
different differing conditions
imposed if also promotes joint working
between local planning
authorities um on in terms of the
location there's a great wood which is
ancient Woodland which adjoins the site
on the Eastern side and canwood which is
also an ancient Woodland um also joins
the site and both are local areas local
Wildlife
sites this plan um is to illustrate the
public right of way that got run through
and around the site so you've got public
right of way number eight along the
western boundary which is also a bridal
way and the pro right of way number
seven which by sex of site is a foot
path number 14 is along the proposed
access and number 10 is further south to
of the site these and these are all foot
paths development does not require any
alterations to these public right of
ways there is a power line that runs
across the Southeastern corner site
denoted by the dotted
line
this is the proposed layout so the far
north of site is located in a highrisk
flood zon um but there's no operational
development proposed in this location
the development will be provided in
Parcels each consisting of solal panels
and medium voltage power stations the
majority of the incin structures will be
located in parcel 4 closest to the site
AIS which is down here um the
construction period is anticipated to
the last 24 weeks being taken day to
Fridays during the operational phase
it's expected that there will be only
one vehicle movement either weekly or
fortnightly this is the Landscaping
plan um all existing hedro and trees are
to be retained and reinforced where
appropriate hedro planting is proposed
along the public right of way to reduce
impacts on the development for users of
that footpath the brandes will also
consist of deer fencing and CCTV mounted
on posts wildfly planting is proposed in
and around the arrays as well as in the
northern part of the site scrub and tree
planting is also proposed in areas
outside of the development zones a
drainage trench is proposed in the
southern part of the site in its Center
running north to south as well as
smaller ones running east to west no
lighting is proposed other than
emergency infrared
lighting this illustrates the
agricultural land classification of the
site which is all grade 3B
land and then we've got some elevations
of floor plans of this is the private
substation
distribution Network operator
substation um a multiv voltage Power
Station
substation space
container and these are the um solar
panels themselves in cross-section and
also elevation down the bottom and then
we've got um details of the fencing CCTV
and the satellite dishes
so these are some of the site photos to
illustrate the site as it is today um so
and the the um star show the position of
the person taking the photos this is the
access into the site there's a dwelling
next to the um that
access again looking back down towards
Crow
Lane site photos quite a typical rural
field
again more this will be approximately
where the um the main ancillary
structures the um substations will be
going be from the prate rights
away again more views up and down the
site views from the public right away
which bisects the
site again the same same from the same
position ones from further slightly
further
north and again those on the um eastern
boundary more from the from the same
back same
position so the proposed development
would result in some adverse impacts to
the existing landscape but the impacts
will be limited to immediate receptors
such as the users of the public right of
way and residents along hman L but these
could be M mitigated by the proposed
Landscaping therefore ensuring that the
impacts are not significant or
unacceptable the impacts are also
temporary given the 40-year lifespan of
the development and any adverse e
ecological impacts could be suitably
dealt with through mitigation to be
secured by conditions the same applies
in relation to any potential impacts on
the highway Network including the public
rights of way it's also been found that
there will be no harm caused to
neighboring Heritage assets having full
regard to the concerns raised by star's
Great War War Aerodrome there would also
be no adverse impacts in terms of glint
and glare or the operation of the
aerodrome and flights to and from it and
no impacts to residential immunity
highways impacts during the construction
period having specific regard to the
impacts on the public right away can be
suitably managed by conditions and there
are no highways concerns raised during
the operation phase the community
impacts of of a previously approved
solar farm in Haz Lee have also been
taken into consideration and it's found
that the two schemes would not be not
dally impact on one another
development would deliver a net bi
biodiversity gain and would provide a
source of renewable energy which is
supported by national and lo local
policy therefore in balancing the
benefits against adverse impacts the
developments considered the benefits
would outweigh the harm as such the
application is recommended for approval
thank you thank you very much indeed m
Matthews we have a a member of the
public to speak is Mr Duncan Hoy who's
the applicant Mr Howe are you here
you've been before haven't you
no okay so what you do is is you could
be kind enough to find a seat slide
around that's it yeah ccel thank you
very
much sorry we've also got an obor for
that application okay certainly thank
you that wasn't um earlier on um um Miss
Middleton thank
you chair counselers my name is dunan
how just bear with me one second Sorry
Miss Middleton sorry my apologies it
wasn't written down that you was
intended so sorry about that so I've got
to do the protocols um Mr Hoy you have
two minutes from the time you start
speaking um and two minutes does go
rather quickly so thank you chair
counselors my name is Duncan hoe and I'm
a director of Ang Renewables this
proposal is for the construction of a
solar farm for the generation of
renewable energy your officer has
recommended this application for
approval and I will set out compelling
reasons why we ask you to support this
project solar is a source of cheat power
something we badly need as we are
gripped by the cost of living
crisis Sol also provides much needed
energy security for this nation reducing
our alliance on foreign fuel Imports
solar is Renewable Power and we must
take action at a local level to reduce
our alliance on dirty fossil fuels and
Tackle climate
change M District Council has declared a
climate emergency and published a
climate action strategy with aspirations
to be a carbon neutral District by 2030
to lead by example and encourage
businesses residents and parishes to
make positive changes reduce use of oil
natural gas and coal and support the
green energy sector to secure lowcost
low carbon energy
supplies the delivery of this solar farm
will help meet all of those aspirations
and Tackle climate change at a local
level this site is land grade 3B and not
considered best and most versatile land
the site will be grows by sheet to offer
dual use of energy and agriculture
alongside significant elogic ecology
enhancements the landscaping and ecology
proposed will result in a 77% bi
biodiversity net gain and a 46% increase
in hedro
units in conclusion this application is
strongly supported by policy has no
statutary consulty objections and your
planning officer has in her professional
judgment concluded that the application
should be approved
I hope all the benefits to you the
nation and our environment will bring
you to that same conclusion and that you
can vote in favor of this application
thank you thank you Mr Harry you very
much
indeed so uh Miss Middleton as an
objective would you care to take your
seat thank
you and again soon as you're comfortable
we got two two minutes um as soon as you
start speaking the clock will start
running down
again thank you chair um I'm
representing the crib the Warren and the
IV house it wasn't demonstrated in any
other the photographs there we are only
140 um meters away from this um alleged
uh or this a planned position there's
three families there so we are the small
people up against a larger organization
our points here are very much in the
vinity of the private dwelling houses
and what the effect will have on us as a
very young family and a very older
family in this particular area um
concerned around zones two and three of
the water across the tops so um and
obviously from a point of view that we
should be looking at Brownfield sites
rather than 3B graded sites um
stipulations about no glare on 5.41 5.43
well we're within 1 kilometer if you
look at the um restricted areas in there
um the noise impact um greater at noon
on 5.4 54 well climate change is going
to have us an issue in respect to the
noise if they're applying fans in the
area
the animal boxes and the nature
attraction and doing something around
there great that's wonderful but you're
going to push the deer out into the road
of Hackman's Lane um the boundaries the
birds that are he thinking it's water um
Birds of Prey particularly kites that we
see and Twitches that we have in the
area um the solar farm west of Hackman
which was agreed on in 20 2015 was away
from any premises whatsoever it's
wrapping around historic L Woodland if
you look on the actual um areas fire
risk on there um obviously we're saying
not in backyard but we are saying please
can you put it further away from from
the area um objections on sing the local
connections on health um EMF for us move
it away from our properties um closer to
vicinity high voltage higher the risk um
neighbors discussed with the PE PE
Parish Council who at least suggested if
if this is looked to be approved that
they should at least move it away from
these private dwellings um away from
what we're doing um what will the
condition look like in 40 years time I
hope I'll be alive in 40 years
time thank you sorry I'm not first to
doing this normally so hopefully
absolutely fine thank
you thank you very much
indeed thank you councilor Laban for
making that happen so seamlessly um
members we have a recommendation to
approve subject to conditions set out in
Section 8 of the report is that
seconded okay members I'll open the
chamber to debate councelor white um
thank you Mr chairman um I mean this is
in my ward and um I have to say that I
can see where the although I hardly
support Sola I do think it is too close
to the residential houses I mean how
many meters is that away because I'd
only thought about it from the other
side and it's only hearing what the
member of the public has come up with
and looking on the map I've realized how
close to the crib it is because obvious
the crib is set back off of Hackman's
Lane and it's quite a way back down a
little track to where the houses
actually are um so I wonder if you going
tell me how far away it is um from
that's the first one and when you go
down to the 5.6 which is all the
biodiversity um it it's talking about
doing it after the event and I'd like to
have seen it before although they're
saying they'll have an achievement of
plus
77.6 very little seems to have been done
um in the biod diversity about the um
ancient
Woodland and the other question I had is
under
22261 full um that also uses a road
which I objected to solar farm there
because the road in my mind was too
small and again it it's hypocritical
because I like solar Farms but it has to
be the right location and were there any
complaints whatsoever um about the lores
using that road um during
construction thank you Miss
Matthews um thank you chairman um I can
um measure the distance um if I have a
moment um but the the crib is is here
and solar farm is here
obviously not right next door um I I'd
need to measure that um distance to give
you an accurate distance away
um in terms of Bio biodiversity before
not later on
um the um in terms of um planning
controls it would be unreasonable to ask
for biodiversity or any sort of
improvements UPF front before the
development even even started um that
that's quite a standard requirement and
standard conditions that that we applied
um to this case as as in
others um the ancient Woodland is
actually not within the application site
boundary so in terms of biodiversity net
gain or diversity improvements on that
land that wouldn't be within the control
of the applicant because it's not within
their their land ownership um I'm not
aware about complaints about other other
Sol of farms it doesn't mean there were
any but um if if had been any they
wouldn't have necessarily come via the
the the planning department but we would
I think the the standard response would
be in terms of that would be um it is a
temporary situation um does quite a lot
of construction sites that do cause
quite a lot of disruption but it's only
a temporary period and that's normally
accepted as being um um not a
satisfactory situation but it it's
limited and construction management
statements and conditions can be imposed
to ensure that any disruption and is
minimized as much as possible thank you
m Matthews counc white thank you chman
for allowing me to come back um yeah I
mean my my query really is is that if
this was a single house you would want
all the environmental and the nature
studies done first if somebody wanted to
build one dwelling house next door to
the ancient Woodland um and that hasn't
been done which I'm concerned about the
other thing is if it was a house they
would talk about the effect that it has
and that would probably be a reason for
refusal um oh and the last thing I meant
to mention in my first question was
under um five under the objections or
from the comments from the great um air
War Museum um they were asking for an
Aon nautical impact assessment and I
looked down 5512 and I couldn't actually
see one so was one carried out because I
know when the application at flambo's
Farm went in which I actually supported
as I've supported most of the other
solar Farms um that was one something
they wanted done I can't remember if it
was done or not but I was just a bit I
know you're talking about less glare but
why wasn't that put in for this
application and we still don't know how
far away it is from the crib thank you
thank you counc m Matthews thank you um
it's been measured 140 M at its closest
point to to the
crib I'd have to work that out
um bit
longer um three in a
bit that's
pretty I think um I think what officers
would say in terms of this the
development that he's proposed is um
because of because it being a solar Farm
if it was wind turbines for example
obviously being that close there would
be more of an impact but solar Farms are
very quiet um low low-lying um
developments that can be can be fairly
easily screened with um existing and
proposed vegetation so um and and the
conclusions I mean it's been fully
assessed as part of the report and the
conclusion is um that it would be
acceptable um and um which is comparable
to to to other other similar proposals
um that have been considered by the
council
um in terms
of
surveys or I'm covering for um for Devon
who's unable to make it this evening so
I'm
not as familiar as she would have been
with the report but
um about surveys for
Ecology I would have thought there would
been one done before the application
came in or was part of the application
and we would have consulted our ecology
experts um oh hang on got message from
Deon um they've submitted an assessment
looking at the impacts of on the
aerodrome oh sorry that's the next next
question
um wonders of Technology yeah so we've
consulted um ESS County ccil ecology and
they've got no objection so in terms of
ecology and assessing the impact in
terms of information that's been
submitted that's that's been considered
to be acceptable with this type of
development um if it was a different
type of development um housing May
mentioned then then there may have been
needed other assessments or different
assessments may have been needed and
certainly in terms of impact on ecology
um Housing Development would much be
more likely to have um a different
effect than um a Sol Farm um and then in
terms of
the um aeronautical
survey um they submitted an assessment
looking at the impacts on the air Drome
following the concerns that have been
raised and found that there will be no
glint and glare other than momentary
flashes and would be likely to be under
the planes it also wouldn't impact
significantly on the area available for
emergency landing so that matter has
been has been considered and responded
to in light of the objections that have
been raised and no harm um just no harm
has been found that certainly that would
justify a a refusal of planning
permission thank you thank you m
Matthews members any other member Mr to
speak councelor
fluka and chairman first question chman
whenever we hear about solar Farms we
hear about sheep and and I won't tell
well I may tell that world rehears story
of mine that's when we went to have a
look at a solar farmer six eight years
ago I think Council white was there and
we saw all the sheep and we stopped at
the Village Pub on the way home and we
saw them all again in a lorry being
taken away um but anyway genten that's
that is a well rehearsed story so my
first question uh bearing in mind the uh
what the applicant said I wonder whether
or not we could condition this chairman
so that they do in fact gra sheep there
because I I don't think ordinarily it's
possible uh bear in mind the ask most of
which is in
the well I'm sorry m Matthews I think
the chairman wants to answer that so
yeah I've I've sought some advice and uh
we can't condition sheep we can't
condition
sheep Mr Johnson I think we any um but
chman I just wanted to uh go back to
what the objector said and
I I wasn't quite sure if she said 114 m
or or
cancel the bone was as close to as I was
almost and he seems to think it's
so one would think if you've got a uh
residential dwelling house 100 odd
meters away from um this solar farm um
bearing in mind the height of these
panels off the
ground um it's completely different to
you know if you're a long way away from
these it's fine but when you're within
100 m and you've got something that's
sort of 2 and 1 half M high or whatever
I appreciate there's a fence and you've
got a fence as well so what does that
look like how does that enhance the
living conditions of the people um and
you know how does it protect and enhance
the character of that particular area
and particularly around that house you
know to me it doesn't sit well with
policy D1 from which all of those
comments come from jman and and I would
be very very concerned chairman at the
height size and scale of massing in
relation to the distance between the
house and the solar array so I'm I'm
very concerned but I'll give way to
because I know that councilor stamp want
say do you have any comment to make
before we move on to councelor stamp um
I just um I just perhaps say that um I
don't think there officers were saying
that the anyone who lives around there
will not be able to see it um I think
it's a knowledge that that it may well
be visible but that but that that's a
long way from saying something is
harmful because somebody can see
something doesn't necessarily mean it's
mean it's harmful um and and has also
acknowledged as part of the report that
there would be some harm to the
character and appearance of the era but
that is outweighed um in officers views
quite significantly by the benefits of
the proposal and which again all set out
in the report thank you thank you m
Matthew coun stamp please mine was
really I don't know a lot about solar
Farms I think we all want to support
them because we realize the energy
crisis are in but um I do have some
sympathy with the uh um resident uh the
the lady who spoke I don't know anything
about it Miss Matthews do you get a lot
of glare off them are they are they
going to be situated where the the
residents and a family or his family
won't be affected by them um and is
there any evidence that they cause harm
if they're too close to anybody it's
like the old pylons thing or the mobile
phones thing years ago is there any
actual evidence that harm can be caused
to anybody if they're close to
them thank you Matthews
report through through your CH the
um again as officers we can't say there
will be no there will be no glint and
glare from from the solar panels because
of their their their very nature and the
when the sun's out there there will
there inevitably be some but
again that's a long way from saying that
that that would be harmful um and has
has been assessed and and weighed up as
part of the um assessment of The
Proposal um in terms
of evidence of harm I'm personally not
aware of any evidence not not in the
same way that there has been evidence of
other other uses and mobile phone mass
and and and things like that in the past
so um um no and environmental health
have been Consulting on the application
and again they've not come back with any
objections that that could substantiate
a reason for refusal I mean that's what
we're looking at aren't we not not
whether something could be better or
there would be any any adverse impact
whatsoever thank you very much indeed
y just as a point of clarity could the
officer just highlight on the screen
where the crib
is through chairman I it's this location
here I understand
so the um the the lady who who stood up
and spoke said there was a photo there's
a property on the on the axess way down
here um so that was a photo of that and
she commented that hadn't been a photo
of her property but but that's on on the
other side um over here so for cloud sh
the crib is actually where the pointer
is at the moment yes that says crib so
access the crib from Hackman's Lane
rather than um Crow Lanes
yes so there's there's an access way um
and
there's off the officer
[Music]
confirm how the solo panel which way
they face I presume
Southwest no well the Sun is up at
midday so I don't think that's right I
don't think they followed the ones that
uh
so the
um this is the area part the site that
would be nearest to the crib if we
compare that to to that to in this this
area here and that's the layout of the
solar panels in so chairman they just
all they will see chairman is basically
a black wall because when you look
Downstream at a solar farm it's just a
black mass uh which brings me back to
what the officer says you know this very
uh subjective issue of harm versus
benefit and I I I'm I'm sorry but I
think from where Mrs Middleton is coming
from um I think the harm to her and the
residents to her property would would
outweigh any benefit from this and and
and I'd hope chairman if if if Council
or the planning committee were mindful
to refuse this application perhaps the
panels could be moved further away from
her
property counc um just before move on to
council Morgan public speaking um
protocol Miss mid is just that two
minutes I'm afraid so thank you
councelor Morgan
please yeah thank you Mr chairman U one
of my most favorite bits of music is Ray
form Williams's lck ascending and I can
see that um putting a solo Farm on top
of this it will be significant
disruption to those beautiful Bird's
nesting habits and I noticed in Clause
5.6.5 there is a Skylock mitigation
scheme and that two compensatory Skylock
plots will be provided within land under
the applicant's ownership through you
chair could the officer confirm that
those plots would be of similar size and
near enough so any displaced sky loocks
in that area have somewhere to
Nest the chairman I not without looking
through the file I don't have that
information to hand but this this would
have been on the back of the essis
County Council col especially um
agreeing to the the mitigation package
that they were proposing as being
acceptable as no acceptable compensation
for any loss that this development would
would have resulted or will result would
result in um it yeah that's probably all
I can say without going through the file
and and seeing more of the details but
it as officers we we take we get
specialist advice on these matters and
that's what they're telling us so we've
got no reason to doubt that yeah thank
you thank you m Matthews so members we
we've had a recommendation to approve
which I put to the chamber earlier and
that wasn't seconded is that still the
case Council fluk you second
that anybody seconding in it chairman I
I would propose chairman that uh the
committee uh refuses this application uh
under policy D1 in so far as uh it
hasn't been demonstrated that the
subjective issue of harm versus benefit
uh weighs in favor of development
uh and this is specifically in relation
to the crib chairman thank you is that
that's a proposal from the floor is that
seconded members second Bo by Council
bound um members those
members yes you can and I just say that
I have concerns that it doesn't appear
that an aeronautical impact assessment
was done either okay thank you noted so
I do support it I do support solar Farms
but I just think that that last bit that
sticks out is just too much well we have
a a proposal that's been um tabled we've
had that proposal seconded members um
could I have a show hands for that
proposal to refuse based on councelor
fla's recommendations because you put
your hands up quite high for me please
so you can here one two three four five
six 7 8 9 10 11 12 133 do you make that
13 yes 13 so it's 13 for those against
members please raise hands one two three
four five 6 7 8 nine 10 that's 10
against okay any
abstentions one absten so two
abstentions because I'll abstained so
that motion is carried in favor of
refusal as per Council fluker's proposal
members thank you very much
indeed we move on to agenda item six
which is reference
FM this is land Northwest of molden Road
Burnham on Crouch this is found on pages
47 to 92 and there has been a members
update issued on this matter as well
members uh again uh Miss Matthews you're
pres presenting this
item
just bear with us a moment members
technical
issues
okay thank you okay me thank
you yeah so yeah so thank you the
um there was um there' been no formal
well until today there was no update for
the application but I would draw members
attention the update that was um emailed
around early this evening um which
references is re relevant to the parts
of report which talks about the fiveyear
housing land Supply and the application
of the tilty balance in this
case so this is an
application shall we um give Mr Johnson
just to give a little bit more of an
update on that well yeah I think that
would think clarity thank you thank you
chairman um it's it's it's fairly
self-evident from the update which has
been circulated but but just to be clear
this report is to be read without
reference to section
5.1.1 uh sets out there it says this
paragraph is to be deleted and no longer
part of this report it does not reflect
the council's current position in that
the local plan policies are not
considered to be out of date tilted
balance therefore is not engaged the
commentary therefore gives some
background to that again just to make it
clear that that paragraph was just uh
unfortunately erroneously put into the
report and in considering this report um
your your considerations will be taken
from 5.1.2 of that report doesn't change
the recommendation in the or it doesn't
change the recommendation in any way
it's just to make it clear um a little
further background to that is that um um
since the publication of the of of the
reports uh we have had um uh approaches
from from from developers obviously
quite Keen to hear that the Tilted
balance um is engaged in some form or
the other um and um that's obviously
quite concerning to us um in terms of
that element of the report which is why
it just needed to make formally clear
that that is to be removed that's not
the council's position thank you very
much indeed Mr Johnson that's very clear
m Matthews thank
you oh you've got detention Bas
retention Bas okay
well if you don't if you don't behave
yourself you know where you're going
that's well
spotted okay that that sure it's
retention Bas okay detention B Miss
Matthews please I don't the water be
water is being detained temporarily so I
don't know whether it
is okay members let's go let's move on
the agenda or I'll um thank you I'll
have that corrected if if indeed it does
need correcting so this is a um site
land Northwest number two molden Road
burn Mon crou and it's a proposal for a
direction of 40 flats and Associate
infrastructure accessways parking
Landscaping construction of an enlarged
retention detention Basin and and
provision of additional parking spaces
for the approved Medical Center so the
site is outside the settlement boundary
for burn mon Crouch but forms part of
phase one of approved development now
known as burn and Waters um Construction
Construction of which is underway um um
the site is north of molden Road East of
Tinker Hall and west of the bur mon
settlement boundary faes two and three
beyond the northern and Eastern
boundaries of phase one also have plan
Mission so phase one was for um a total
of 166 residential units um that's 103
Bungalows 55 Assisted Living units and
eight key key worker units the 7 bed
care home uh it be Community Center
shops Medical Center offices Maintenance
building
minity Area sports facilities um
drainage infrastructure and vehicle
accesses um from the main road in tiners
Hall just um as a
summary so these are location PL showing
the part of phase one that the
application site relates to and this is
essentially the part of the site that
had the planning permission for um the
care home element of phase
one this is um a block plan so it shows
the flat will be in two blocks um both
blocks will be two stories in height
there have been ened Block B Block a and
Block B there'll be 20 Flats in each um
they would have um there would be also
detached cycle bin stores and there's
also the seven additional parking spaces
for the approved Medical Center which is
um down in this corner here and an
extension to the um drainage Bas and not
going to call it now um and that that's
in this area here
these are more more detailed location
plans um layout plans showing the um the
approved layout which shows the care
home in this position here sort of an
L-shaped layout and these are the two
blocks A and B which would uh
essentially take the place of that
building so this is the Landscaping plan
again the two blocks
um some Landscaping going on and showing
the external imunity areas for the
flats and there's some elevations block
a more elevations of block
a ground floor block a this is the one
to the the rear if you
like
um and then you've got Block B
elevations
um the block a will be all one bedroom
flats and Block B will be 12 two
bedrooms and eight one bedroom
Flats so these are elevation um ground
floor plans for the um that block first
floor block floor plans Sor and then
this is that shows the enlargement to
the the detention Basin um which is
these um black Dash lines around the
end and this is the extent of the of the
Basin um we added
to so we've got some site photos of um
work in progress these are taken mainly
from the main road showing the new
access that being put in and some of the
Bungalows that are under
construction views from other parts of
the site views from um Tinker hole and
the um the way in
there so in terms of
um oh actually I would I I do have these
ready if if anybody would like to see
them so these showing the approved
layout for phase one and the care home
in position there again showing the care
home um in its context these are the
Assisted Living units um to this side
theyve got the medical center here they
got the shops here and the sports
facilities
here and just just by way of
illustration the elevations and floor
plans the care home just um by way of
comparison to the blocks that are now
proposed so the um the conclusions
officers have reached is the development
would be acceptable in principle and
would not cause harm to the character
appearance of the site or The Wider area
no adverse issues in relation to the
highway safety access of parking have
been identified and the quality of life
of the occupiers of the pro Flats is
considered to be acceptable there no
issues have been adver issues have been
raised in terms of flood risk and
drainage or n
conservation um and as a result it's
recommended that um plan permission is
granted subject to 106 agreement and
conditions are set out in the officer
report so the and the 106 would in
summary cover Financial contributions um
including to Health Care um Rams um
affordable housing will be provided
either on site or as a financial
contribution there'll be the minibus
service electric Cycles um a minimum age
limit of 55 years management company
being set up um preference for district
residents Etc and that's all in line
with the existing plan permissions and
the 106 is for existing phase one and
and phases two and
three thank you thank you very much
indeed Miss Matthews members we again in
the public participation we have one
public speaker registered Mr row thank
you very much if you could just make
your way to the the
table um thank you Council La
again
again you saw earlier on Mr Ro I'm sure
you'll have the the timer come up on the
screen in a moment um you have two
minutes um once you start speaking once
the timer appears like magic thank you
thank you chairman good evening uh Mr
chairman good evening members I'm Stuart
row I'm the planning director of uh burn
and Waters limited and I'm also the
director of the planning design Bureau
so I wear two hats agent and applicant
this evening I speak in support of the
application the application's been
driven by a lack of any interest in any
affordable housing or from any
affordable housing Association willing
to purchase the approved 50 Independent
Living Extra Care units um these were
approved in 2019 as part of the first
phase of the burn and Waters retirement
community during the Inception of phase
one the council encouraged the provision
of independent Extra Care units um and
that was supported initially by Essex
County Council close to the decision
date the County Council withdrew its
support but the district council
maintained that the type of unit was
appropriate and therefore they were
approved however in the intervening 4
and a half years the affordable housing
markets changed significantly both burn
and Waters so that's us if you like the
applicant and the council's own housing
department have approached all of the
housing associations on the council's
list and a number of others too and none
are willing to take 50 retirement homes
they just don't want them um and none
are willing to purchase any number of
independent Extra Care units there's
just no interest at all the care home is
the only element of phase one uh that's
not required to be delivered by section
106 agreement um Care Home beds are less
necessary um in the district than
self-contained units with care provided
um the uh chairman Housing Partnership
is willing to take uh 20 affordable
apartments which we're proposing um as
part of this application and then we
would pay a commuted sum to the council
for the balance the buildings before you
are no higher than the approved care
care home they occupy a similar
footprint they're designed to reflect
the existing Care Home Building and they
meet all of your design standards so
balanced reports before you which I
commend to the committee I hope that you
can see the benefits and Grant
permission thank you thank you Mr
Ro thank you very so members we have a
recommendation to approve um which is
subject to the applicant entry into a
legal agreement pursuant to section 106
of the Town and Country planning act
1990 as amended to secure the planning
obligations and subject conditions dealt
in Section 8
just bear with me a
second okay do you want to read that
because I'm
strugling Mr
Johnson you sorry it's my it's my
handwriting I just wanted to point out
to members as part of this debate we do
we do have colleagues from our from our
housing department who are at the back
who are able to assist with any
particular questions if if if so needed
thank you chairman I apologize Mr
Johnson my eyesight is not what it used
to be um for many reasons so um yeah
we've put the recommendation to approve
is that seconded
members is that second
by so that is
seconded
so members could I open the floor for
debate
please councilor
Fluker chairman further to what Mr
Johnson says I I think that bear in mind
Mr SS is here this evening and and this
all revolves
around changing one type of housing to
another type of Housing and how's that's
going to impa impact the type of housing
that this District needs I think it
would be really useful to hear from Mr
swords now if he could just give us an
overview of where the council is I think
very thank you and it's Council Thompson
who seconded the motion my
apologies
yeah
thank you Mr swords you have what time
you
need um
so we talking in terms of of independent
Extra Care Living housing or older
person's housing so with regards to
Independent Extra Care Living um some of
the counselors that were here back then
when we looked at phase one will be
aware of the fact of uh we had been
working myself and then the Strategic
housing manager plus the lead for essic
County Council for Extra Care Plus a
working member group that we regularly
met for at least five years uh where we
were looking at trying to get extra care
into the district um we tried very hard
we looked at specific possible sites but
nothing ever came forward um and the
only possibility uh was as it progressed
was the think green uh tinker's whole
scheme um and that's why we supported it
and as has already been noted ess6 were
in support of it but sadly nearer to the
point in time they they withdrew because
it wasn't within the boundary of Burnham
um that was the only Extra Care possible
option on the table um and at that point
in time we still had two major players
housing associations that were
interested in still progressing the
scheme with us sadly since then the
world has changed covid cost of living
interest rates it's called huge problems
for housing associations it's C it's
caused huge problems for local
authorities as we're all aware of that
in trying to meet their strategic
housing needs um and it's got very
difficult now for housing associations
members will probably be aware that very
recently in the last six months two
major housing associations have
withdrawn from this district and sold
their stock because they're trying to
cut back cut costs we've also got
another major Housing Association in
this district 6 months ago they they've
wound down their development department
and have advised me they're not going to
be developing in this District so things
are getting very difficult we still want
to have extra care obviously we need
extra care and we would still like that
to progress I've spoken very recently to
now the new head of Extra Care at ess6
County Council who has advised me that
again they're aware of how difficult
things are for uh housing associations
mainly in terms of them trying to go out
their housing associations and buy the
land and pay for the cost of building
these large schemes because ess6 have
said you need a minimum of 50 or 60 unit
schemes they're very expensive the other
issue is they're very nervous the
housing associations on delivering the
or being involved with the care side of
running of an extra care scheme some of
them aren't geared up up for it some of
them would have to work in partnership
with care agencies and the new care
responsibilities or the Care Act say
that people in these schemes can choose
where they want to get their care they
don't necessarily have to go with the
care provider on site so that becomes an
even greater risk for housing
associations in going into this field so
that's why both the developer has tried
with those housing associations here and
some extra ones and I too have twice I
went around phoning them emailing them
trying to to to get them to come on
board but they have all since pulled
away and declined and they're also being
very very cautious on General needs
affordable housing schemes now they
they're very wary of of what they're
bidding on is very difficult times at
the moment let's hope it
improves um so we are still working with
Essex County Council we do still want to
have an extra care scheme in the
district and I've been advised that from
the lady Essex County Council possibly
the only way that that may ever happen
uh in going forward is if it's on Essex
County council's Land um because then
that saves the costs for the Housing
Association so I think that's it on
Extra Care is that enough on extra y
thank you very much any any further
questions
um just in in summary does the housing
department support this chairman I think
that's the question
that
so yeah from obviously yeah from the
report yes we do support it
because both us and the developer would
like to have some form of of affordable
housing on this site the proposed 20
units would enable us to therefore then
prioritize older people in The District
in social housing in three and four beds
wishing to Downs siiz they would get
priority we are desperate now for three
bed houses as most members know that
would hopefully create a churn for us
and most importantly of all as well
there is obviously the commuted sum that
we're looking at here quite a large
figure that would enable us um to do
other affordable housing projects across
the district supported housing schemes
bringing empty homes back into use who
knows purchasing land modular housing
all the other strategic things that we
have to meet as a as a housing
department now and going forward through
difficult years ahead 5 to 10 years that
would greatly help the housing
department as well so yes we do support
this this scheme thank you Mr swords any
further questions from Mr
swords thank you Mr swords Mr gayor I
think you'd like to know you okay
sure yeah you got your paper you're
welcome
yeah it's very important so thank you
thank you members it's really just a bit
of supplement M and John has already
mentioned possible churn um from from
these units becoming available so I'm
referring to data from our housing
register so just a very rough um
overview we're being proposed uh to
receive 20 units band a um three people
in three beds seeking one bed
accommodation we have 10 people so
potentially that could be 10 people
applying the downsize to this property b
b two bed properties uh looking for one
bed accommodation we have 10 requesting
downsizing and we also have 10
requesting due to medical reasons so
potentially there's 30 people and there
are other numbers here on this list but
that's just a flavor of the possibility
of churn so I just thought that was an
interesting important point to make
thank you thank you very much indeed Mr
G members any other member wish to speak
on the
application don't
off I'm happy to start then everybody
else can follow off me um right now I I
do support older people's um housing but
it is the the wrong housing in the wrong
location but my first point is under
5.3.2 um the previous act application
had a fvia done and what my concerns are
is why hasn't one been done for this
application because there's lots of
rumors swirling around um and what I
wanted clarification of was when did
they start this application I do know
when they started it when did they start
building these houses or the rest of the
development when were they completed how
many have been completed how many have
been sold and how many are occupied and
paying council tax CU I suspect there's
none so that's the first thing so we're
talking about increasing old people's
housing when as far as I'm aware they
haven't got a single house occupied in
however many years the development's
been there so that's my first thing the
second thing is when you look at the Lo
ation this application is by om Farm
which is probably miles from the center
of Burnham I don't know how many miles
it is but it's certainly miles and I
wouldn't be able to walk to burn a moner
out she wouldn't be able to get an old
people's scooter um so that's the next
one um on
5.3.2
2.3 um I mean I yes we need this housing
but I think it's the wrong location but
what I was a bit concerned about is say
the housing management and allocations
manager advised they would support
either option whilst onsite provision is
normally required to comply with policy
H1 they advised that the provision of a
commuted sum equivalent to the 12
affordable units required to comply
would estimate that the council would
achieve 1.6 million in funding well by
the time the council's tried to build
something I'll probably go but what what
that concerns me is so is there
absolutely no intention of the developer
to actually build these flats for a
affordable units anyway that that was
another one if officers could help with
that one um and um the next ones um
under 5.3.1 7 it says we have a in I
think it was 2014 we had a care home
under provision of
1,482 homes the SPD identifies acute
need um the schar in 2014 said the need
was 374 supported units plus 138 Extra
Care units and yet 5.3.1 7.2 ignores
these policies which is 1.2 in favor of
policies 3.4 which aren't supported
which is what the care home was supposed
to be so what in the district is our
over or under Supply now of supported
and Extra Care units because as far as
I'm I'm aware that's what we don't
really have any of um and under 5.3.1
7.6 I've got existing homes with
permission but I can't remember what
that one was for that was a note I made
earlier but really it's about the um
viability impact assessment and the
actual how many residents o over how
many years have we actually got paying
council tax and living in any of these
houses because you can build them but if
it's the wrong location I don't think
you're going to sell them thank you
thank you Council white m Matthews
there's a series of questions
here um yes thank you chairman in terms
of how many are built occupied paying
count tax
um I don't I don't know how many have
actually built they they the development
started um a few months ago um as you
can see from the photos that they're
fairly Advanced stage of of construction
but um whether anyone is actually living
there yet I I don't I don't personally
know but um and but also question
whether
that is how relevant that is to
determining an the current proposal for
um for 40 units instead of instead of
the care home um in terms of viability
assessment one was done um um as part of
the original application it wasn't
necessary for it to be done um the what
the that those sort of assessments are
done where for example developer is
trying to argue that they can't afford
to provide affordable housing or they're
trying to I use the word get out of but
um they're trying to um reduce their
costs um and because they're saying that
they can't the the the the profitability
of the scheme is so low that it wouldn't
um support the normal um commuted sums
and other other Provisions that the
policies would normally ask for so by
not having a viability assessment of
part of this application there wasn't
one for the other two phases further
phases that have have now been got
planned permission again that that's not
um not a an adverse issue in terms of
the the um current application because
the developer is not asking to um
underproof housing it's it's policy
compliant the the level affordable
housing they they're seeking to
provide
um um so in terms of commu some versus
on-site provision this agenda item is is
tied up um and connected quite directly
um with the next agenda item um which I
was trying to um I kept them separate um
because they are separate applications
although there is an certain over
overlap between them um so in
summary um the developer is proposing to
put 20 affordable one-bedroom Flats as
part of this this this application they
they basically that they don't they
don't mind whether that is is the
affordable housing provision for these
extra 40 units or whether it's instead
of or part part part replacement of the
50 units from the phase one um
affordable housing requirement that that
they're already committed to um but the
the summary is there'll be the proposal
is for 20 affordable units one bed units
on on this site on site provision and a
commuted sum for the balance that they
would have um been required to provide
when you add this site with the approved
phase one um the Bungalows and the other
other properties that I mentioned
earlier
166 um in terms of care home need and
extra care home need I think the um for
housing officers have have um mentioned
that earlier and there I think to
summarize that there's a need for all
types of older older persons um living
accommodation in the district um the the
the most recent um local housing needs
assessment suggests that the the
greatest need is for um inhome um um
accommodation rather than the more
specialist provision and that has
shifted and that has changed over the
last few years it was was more care home
um that was more important um and there
was a greatest need for that but that
that that housing mix um for the
district has has changed um I don't
think we're unique in in that so
in terms of whether we need the care
home there's a need for Care Homes but
there's also a need for the type of
accommodation that is that is being
proposed so um so in in terms of
officers assessment there was no reason
to to um object to the current
application on the basis that there will
be essentially the loss of the care home
which was proposed um as part of the
original
application I think that answers um oh
um also asked a question about um how
far from the center of Burnham the this
applic that this development isn't
within the settlement boundary it is a
distance from Burnham toown C Burnham
toown Center um but that matter has has
already been um accepted as not being a
reason for refusal both as part of the
phase one and phases two and three um
and um there's also going to be
contributions or there already have been
contributions secured for um upgrading
public transport provision and there'll
be a Min bus service for the occupiers
of the site and um um access to um
electric bikes for those who are able to
use them but the the the
one one aspect of this proposal which is
perhaps unique to sim to is that there
will be um quite a level of on-site
provision there'll be a Medical Center
sports facilities um shops and um
Community Center th those uses so in
terms of um facilities and Provisions um
there will be less dependence on um the
Town Center as than there would have
been if those ancillary facilities
hadn't been part of the of the proposal
um but but essentially in terms of
accessibility to Burnham Town Burnham
Town Center um I think I would say
that's water under the bridge and and
this and and this this proposal is also
to replace part of the development
that's already been approved it's not
adding to it um it's not extending it
within the confines of the developments
all being approved and replacing um a
building which would have generated a
certain amount of um traffic and um
accessible issues in in its own right
thank you thank you m use councelor
stamp
please wanted to come back quite a
robust question set that councelor white
asked so let members ask us all right um
well I actually wanted to give way to my
fellow members before I actually say
something if that's okay with you
because I don't want to fill everybody's
head with My Views I'd like them to
possibly ask the questions if they've
got any concerns from phase one will
give way to you I was very happy that um
the planning officer m Matthews did
actually refer to phase one phase two
and phase three because I thought we we
were going to be restricted if we could
and I think this needs to be okay we're
talking about this as phase one and the
Amendments um I think it's important is
looked at as a whole because this was
sold to us as a retirement complex
state-ofthe-art etc etc so rever my
rights I wasn't going to speak but I
want other members to come in before I
revert to policies thank you councelor
Bell thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you councilor stamp I mean I think
um we have to listen to our housing
department we may not like this I don't
like it at all I think it's you know
it's something becoming something
completely different it's not what we
were sold and I think there are lessons
to be learned from this I'm a bit
lausted that we would sign something on
um statements of interest rather than
actually signed agreements and I don't
know whether that's you know policy lets
us insist on signed agreements if it
does then I think we should and I think
we need to review the way we deal with
things because a statement of interest
from a supported housing provider is
meaningless now the Care sector was in
crisis before this development was
proposed it's not new we knew this was
going to happen I work in the care
sector we knew this was going to happen
so it's really un very
unfortunate self-fulfilling
prophecy briefly also I don't like
commuted sums I know their government
policy I know their MDC policy I don't
like them because what they mean more
often than not is that the housing
doesn't get built or it gets stuck in a
ghetto somewhere which every bit of
research says is not the way to go
so no I'm not happy about this but I
think as I said we really have to listen
to our housing department and we have to
make the best of what we've got for the
residents of the district thank you and
thank you again councelor Stan councel
Bell there more of a statement questions
any other member wish to speak Council
fto please thank you chair I I tend to
agree with Council Bell I don't have a
problem in terms of the overall
principle of the development I think
where I have concerns is the option as
it seems to be for either the officers
or the developers to depart away from
on-site provision of affordable hous in
and a commuted some now that's I think a
matter that we can address and so
therefore I'm going to propose that
there's a change to the description of
the development to add uh uh in to
include affordable
housing um and also perhaps the terms of
reference so that we we know what we're
agreeing to we should be agreeing to
either commuted some or on site I can't
determine an application based upon the
evidence not knowing what the outcome
would be so that would be my proposal if
I have a second to to change description
and well we have um we have do you have
a a recommendation that's been seconded
so we'd we would have to either agree to
resin that and to adjust it um or to not
approve that and then for you to submit
a second
recommendation because we've already
done the second recommendation at the
beginning so if
um councelor Thompson you know the
recommendation we put in if if we could
I'm happy to remove that
recommendation yes thank you chairman
I'm happy to agree if you if you wish to
take take your proposal and Council fitt
would you like to make your
recommendation um nice and clear so the
officer can I mean this I I I would
recommend approval of the application
but a CH a change to the description and
terms of reference to reflect including
affordable housing in the description
and to remove from the terms of
reference um affordable housing or
commuted sum okay we Mr Johnson you just
want to speak on that for us please just
want to say we can't change the
description of the development that's
been applied
for sorry not unilaterally not without
the agreement the app okay may I come
back chair on that certainly I mean this
obviously is there to avoid a situation
that has arisen with respect to the
application that we're going to be asked
to change the s106 to because it
specifies the provision of affordable
housing so at the end of the day we we
we don't know what we're going to get
whether we're going to get affordable
housing onsite or or whether we're not
and I don't really think that's an
appropriate position for us to be left
in Mr Johnson any
comment Matthews yeah thank you um and
and the other point I was going to make
about the change of description include
affordable housing a description doesn't
have to have affordable housing in it
for affordable housing to be provided um
it's quite common for an a description
of residential development to be um
residential development of 100 houses
and then as
then as part of their proposal in their
supplementary documents s and plans
they'll say well the these these
properties are going to be affordable
housing um and these are going to be
Market housing or we're not providing
any affordable housing on site we we off
we're offering you the the money instead
um
so I that that's what I was thinking um
in terms of the description it doesn't
need to be there for the council to
secure affordable housing as part of
that development that through the 106
agreement um which will be needed if if
before Plan before plan permission is is
granted and it's quite clear that the
the applicant is willing to provide 30%
affordable housing either on site or or
as a commuted sum um in terms of whether
to decide whether it's going to be on
site or commuted
sum um I I I can understand where you're
you're coming from and
um the problem with with this
application in some ways is it so so
tied up with the next agenda item so
what what is decided about the next
agenda item might influence what happens
um what might have happened with with
with this agenda item but um I don't
know whether there's any way of having a
resolution that will allow the
flexibility to have either or but um
depending on what happens with the next
agenda item to um to reflect or not
necessarily change the resolution that's
made on this application um because they
they
are they are quite um quite closely
linked together
um um I'm I'm trying to think of a way a
way of doing it that would allay members
concerns which I understand and I don't
don't don't disagree with um um but a
way of not moving the item forward um
hopefully in a positive way um without
fo fettering any discretion or any
decision making that might be made in
terms of the the next agenda item um I
don't know whether it's possible to put
this gender item on a hold and go to the
next one and then come back to this one
I that's obviously never known that been
done but um I'm just can do it has been
done experience I mean there so I mean
they're just two elements of of the same
development really one is the
development itself one is high is
procured through um a section
106 in in other cases they may just be
one
application it's just that in this case
there just happens to be two
applications as part of the mechanism
okay but while we we think a couple of
other members Council fic wants to come
back councelor fluka and then councelor
white so Council F it's just for a
matter of clarification it's my
understanding that this is a separate um
application and there'll end up being
two applications one for phase one as is
and this will be a second application
that either can be implemented or not
there is nothing to ensure that this
application will be implemented that's
for the developers understand it so I
understand that there's an element of
linking in terms of the wording of the
s106 and things like that but if the
developer decides not to develop this
site this faulty then there's nothing we
can do about it is
there through you tmin the um the based
on legal advice I've I've had um that
the that the two would be would be
linked so that
um the affordable housing um the
variation that the seeking of the
approved phase one um that wouldn't be a
to progress Beyond a certain um certain
number of dwellings on phase one until
affordable housing had been provided
either as commuted some or as part of
this scheme um if it's going to be on
site um so so that there there would be
a link between the two and the certainly
if it was going to be on-site provision
there would need to be on-site provision
before the phase one that's already been
approved could progress Beyond a certain
number of dwellings so there would there
would be that security if you like that
um either the money would be paid or the
on-site provision would be made or well
the on-site provision will be made um
and commuted sum would be paid um at
certain trigger points in in the in the
in the wider development so that that is
a matter that and that that can be done
um the wording would need to be um
sorted out with with the solicitors um
and obviously the plan permission would
not be would not go out until
um that had been signed and sealed and
and our our solicitors Council
solicitors were were happy with the
mechanisms that were in in place within
the agreement um to secure the
affordable housing provision in its
totality um um yes so there is there is
that the security will be there but the
word that exact wording and exactly how
it would happen would need to be subject
to which is it is quite a normal process
um to happen in in certainly in the
major major housing scheme such as this
thank you
cuk Mr
G I just just make sure you've got the
microphone please Mr G thank
you thank you again thank you if I can
just add a bit of supplementary
information just to give a bit of
reassurance uh we have a registered
provider that's in late stage discussion
with the developer for the purposes of
taking on the 20 affordable units um
they've agreed a price so as far as we
understand it so in terms of are we
getting affordable housing on site yes
we are um in terms of the commuted sums
we have an understanding about how that
will progress but just to assure you in
terms of delivery of on-site affordable
housing it's in those late stage
discussions as far as we're concerned
it's prominent it's thank you and I
might add that actually this that is an
unus that is that is an unusual
situation to be in and that we do have
this extra security or peace of mind
that there is an affordable NRP sitting
in the Wings waiting to come in and do
this and normally when permission is
granted no idea who the RP is going to
be until much later in the process when
the developer gone out to see whether
there's anyone interested in the housing
that they're providing um so in this
case I think there's perhaps more
security than than would normally be the
case thank you very much Council fluka
you're next on the yeah thank you
chairman i' sort of saw this coming and
and I was rather hoping that the monitor
officer might be here or somebody from
his may have been here this evening to
advise us but it seems to me from what
um Miss Matthews says that we can
actually tie this up in a way that I
think will satisfy Council fter con
certainly I think the concerns of others
if this is a case and correct me if I'm
wrong Miss Matthews look as though
you're in for the Long Haul
now um I think what you were saying was
that this could be conditioned in such a
way that we do not we can agree the
officer
recommendation subject to the
determination notice not being issued
until we're totally satisfied that this
is for one of the better were completely
screwed down with regards to what's
supplied where and if that is correct
chairman I would propose that we agree
the officer's recommendation because
through that process um we can achieve
what we want to
achieve okay is that seconded members
second Council Morgan thank
you okay and I think chairman just just
with the caveat if you'll excuse me that
perhaps chairman the in the normal way
that we often deal with these things um
the the determination notice the
conditions of it I actually agreed with
yourself and perhaps Council of fittex
and the MERS and then that way we've got
it covered off conjunction of council
ftic obviously the officers thank you um
the the conditions part getting mled
between terminology but conditions the
conditions are recommended in the papers
and there wouldn't be the
normal wouldn't normally expect those to
be agreed again or further along the
lines um but um I need perhaps want to
be quite sure exactly what circumstances
you'd expect to be involved with any any
um wording of any 106 agreement because
that's not normally something that that
no members don't get involved don't get
in them so i' be just just to clar
exactly how how your involvement would
um uh how detailed or how involved you
you would expect to be why would think
that I think it would be fair and
Equitable that once you've develop the
wording that we're just informed of that
okay okay so the the before the 106 is
signed you mean yeah okay yeah okay um
we've got councelor white you wanted to
come back and then counselor stamp uh
thank you Mr my mine was really just to
see um what happened to the
2014 um need for
1,482 Care Home beds did that just
vanish do we not have any need for Care
Homes anymore because it's not mentioned
again and I would have thought with the
Aging population it's mentioned further
down in the report that the care home
provision has actually increased and the
fact that it's located miles outside the
Town Center is less of a an issue if
it's a care home than if it's housing so
that I'm still didn't get an answer as
to where that um need has gone unless we
don't have any more need in this
District that's not something to be
answer under this okay yeah it's thank
you thanks for the question but we won't
answer that under this report um
councelor stamp
please yeah thank you Mr chairman um
just for the benefit of the newer
members you can stop me if you want or
or you know but I think we need to put
some of this in perspective I know know
um I really shouldn't go beyond uh
history go back backwards um but we I I
am taking a little bit of exception
because U this development was sold to
provide a One-Stop shop we were supposed
to be having this development that you
went in for assisted living or a care
home dementia it was all supposed to be
bells ringing dancing and everything to
provide for the whole District not just
burn them on Crouch uh and and going
back to say uh the statute con T wrote
to this Council on the 14th of December
2018 and it was mentioned by the Mr row
I think and uh Mr swords but it says
quite categorically in that letter from
ESS County Council that it was not
supported uh um and I won't read it all
out because hopefully members have read
lots of documents as as some of us do
because of its isolation risks and void
social isolation for customers and risk
of care delivery well if you want to uh
deliver assistant care Cent care units
you have to think about providing that
care it's all right coming back three or
four years later when the the world's
changed what's going to say that the
next time I mean I've read the report
quite a lot of time quite a number of
times and I'm surrounded by papers
because I'm still not convinced that
this is going to be delivered it it says
in the report that the um Care Home may
be delivered we've got a a development
following next uh with uh uh uh David
homes who on the original planning
permission for that when it was granted
at this council did have an allowance
for a care home we are going to view the
next gender item but one because it's a
section 106 thingy about that very
scheme because this development we're
talking about here superseded and
everybody else left the market they
couldn't provide a care home they
couldn't do this because this is what
you're getting you are going to get this
d uh modern District Council let me just
go back to policy
s612 a significant portion of proposed
dwellings for burnam on Crouch are of a
formed tenure and dwelling mix that is
appropriate for meeting the housing
needs of older population including the
provision of Bungalows sheltered housing
Extra Care housing private retirement
homes and lifetime homes right so that's
one policy let's go to the housing
policy H3 and this is accommodation for
special needs or people that I think we
we need to be caring for and I don't
this is not special needs as in special
needs as in send this is our elder
population as well and it it says quite
clearly here um about our policies and
as far as I'm concerned h367 and 8 are
not actually being adhered to I'm not
going to read them all out members
because you're going to get absolutely
Fed Up of me talking about it but I hope
you have read it another thing before we
go any
further what what really is concerning
me is that I don't want this community
muted sums For What burnam on Crouch is
getting this huge huge development which
at the moment yeah we've not been
provided with the viability I'm not
going to deal with gossip uh uh and and
inuendo uh because whether this is
viable or not this Council has a duty to
to check if it's viable it's all right
coming back and saying oh you can't have
it cuz no we've got no care provider I
can remember in a conversation I have to
be careful about this with Mr gayer and
it was under private confidential so
can't say too much and that our world
members would talked about this and I
said something similar to what um uh
councelor Bell said how on Earth can you
say you're going to deliver something
without having something a bit more
concrete and I know chairman you're
going to say to me councelor stamp you
haven't really ask many questions my
question is I don't think that we should
accept the base level of 40 Flats 20
that's been provided by CHP for a huge
development with phase one two and three
that is bigger than the God knows how
many villages already in the in the MN
District stuck on the the outside now if
people read the planning inspector uh uh
pins review on phase two this is
supposed to be that it fits its own
needs it's supposed to serve its own
Community it's supposed to have a
private medical center there uh and and
they're supposed to be able to stay
there it's all right saying we're going
to put electric buses and electric
scooters I live on the molden road if
people getting an electric scooter I've
already had people who's fell off them
and had to bring into my house the
mobility scooters and ring somebody to
come and pick their granny up or their
granddad because they've fallen off
their scooters because of the traffic
and it's a lot busier than now so I know
that the offices are going to say
Council stamp they're not planning
reasons particularly I think they are
because this is actually what's going to
make that Su that site a success or is
it just going to be left undeveloped and
it's just going to be Market housing we
have a duty John sword says all the time
Council St we haven't got enough
affordable housing this is not
delivering affordable housing in Burnham
and the denji I did a little survey
about the percentage of um 65s 55s and
over and there's only small section here
Burnham has got 41% of 55 and overs all
Thorn's got 53 South min's low 34 I'm
surprised cancel fluka I think I
included you in that one Mand 39 and
Bradwell 4
so you know we have got an agent did did
you hear that we have got an aging
population and we do need to deliver and
not everybody is affluent not everybody
can afford one of these Bungalows and I
think I've written this down and you can
correct me if I'm wrong I think it's oh
the well can't is not allow to speak 378
Bungalows 160 Apartments 70 Care Home 70
bed care home with 55 Assistant Living
was what it was at the end of phase
three what are we going to end up with
now I know I'm passionate I'm passionate
about Burnham and I'm passionate about
this District if a developer or an
applic whatever comes in with a scheme
we have to put faith that they're going
to deliver it and it's all right saying
covid the cost of bricks have gone up
this is happened to every Builder up and
down the country it's not just molden
Centric or entric so I'm I'm afraid I
don't have a lot of sympathy which I
know a lot of you know I don't have a
lot of sympathy about many things but
why do we have to throw this out now why
can't the developer then turn around and
say I mean it says quite clearly we may
deliver the care home deliver the care
home we why can't they at a later stage
in phase two and phase three which we're
not going to have any affordable sites
on affordable houses on site as it
stands at the moment or very few why
can't they come back and say the market
may have changed members we'll have your
assisted living there and and and you
know I'm sorry I'm passionate and I
maybe been a little bit unfair to uh to
this developer but we really should be
delivering you can't keep telling
members to vote things through uh
because you're because of x y and Zed
and then not delivering what it says on
the actual application so I'm sorry yeah
I understand that councilor Bell has
turned around and said we we have to
agree with it I will only agree well I
won't agree with it oh did you sorry I
thought I thought yeah okay it's fine
it's we're all right we're used to it
but but I would say I'm not happy with
commuted sums so if members I don't know
if councelor fitt could help me out on
this one I don't want the commuted stms
to go over in the district it should not
have taken this thing should not have
taken place uh to the size it is and
then say well I'm going to put five or
six or 10 million to somewhere else it
was quite categorically said do not
build it in Burham Essex County council
did not support it it said M than town
and I did a quick survey about places
who have Assisted Living units and they
have them in was it brain tree I think
it brain Tree South End Leon SE there's
some fantastic places that can manage to
do it why can't we sorry but thank you
chairman thank you councilor m Matthews
any response um I don't think there's
much more to add there was it was about
the commuted sums about it if if you
could give us advice on that because I
don't agree that it should go to a big
pot of money when I don't know what
policy we're going to use to spend it
councilor white was absolutely right if
we get 10 or 12 million or whatever
where is it going to go who's it going
to go to is it going to go
wasted
the the um that that might be more
appropriately answered maybe by the um
Housing Services as they are here I
could I I know what the answer is
probably going to be but probably best
to hear it from the horse's mouth as
they say because they it is something
that has been discussed and I know it
has been discussed at quite high levels
in in the council certainly officer
level and um there is a plan I
understand thank you let's move on to Mr
G thank you thank you I may need to to
link it with Mr swords as well just for
a bit of something tag team what you
like thank you thank you um so really ju
just to try and clarify as far as we're
concerned we're expecting affordable in
Phase One 20 properties we're expecting
affordable in phase two um we've already
had those discussions within both the
phases we are expecting some form of
commuted sums to accompany um those
those allocations phase three is still
um something that we're negotiating on
um so in terms of um no provision within
phase two affordable housing there is a
provision for affordable housing as far
as we're concerned the discussions have
been in relation to one and two bed
bunglow and that is referenced in our um
in our supporting document uh in terms
of commuted sums um what will it be
spent on how will it be used will it
just sit in a in a pot and be lost um
the commuted sums is for the purpose of
providing affordable housing across the
whole District that is true and members
can control and shape how how that's
that's used an example that there's been
a different application that we we
brought forward that we're intended to
use commuted sums for when members were
able to to vote that through and and
decided it was appropriate for the
council to move forward with the
purchase um so the Comm sums that we get
projects that we develop are brought to
members you guys shape how we use it
whether that's in Burnham or whether
that's elsewhere in the district and if
it's a case of trying to focus for
something specific for Burnham housing
can focus on that and try and work to to
provide something specific
I was there any other sorry rather than
Hano through you chair absolutely fine
build them in
Burnham this this site is supposed to be
building the affordable housing build
them on this site so you've got a
balanced community of people because if
you're not all you're going to have is
and I'm going to say it Elite rich
people who can afford to build the to
live in those expensive Bungalows and
you're going to have the other the other
people in in Mo whoever the housing
provider is with very little we we have
a duty to provide affordable housing
that has got accessibility to the shops
the pool whatever is going to be
delivered if it's going to be delivered
because we don't know if that is going
to be delivered the first hurdle has not
been delivered so as far as I'm
concerned Why can't the developer build
some of those now up front instead of
waiting later further down you can't
answer that but that's just a general
thing so thank you a statement yeah
thank you Mr Gay Mr s you to add
any no no no you're okay council fluk at
last time to come back thank
you I'll make it a long one chairman I
two minutes starting from there yeah
that'll be this is a very important
debate chman I just I just wanted to
talk to 106 agreements because
presumably this commuted some will be
dealt with through section 106 agreement
and it's not unusual for section 106
agreements whatever they are um that
they only apply to a certain area
because I've I've often tried to dip
into the pot of Burnham to spend in
South minut and I can see them all
ganging up on me so chairman I I really
wanted to to ask chairman whether or not
and bearing in mind that Burnham is
shall we say for one of a better
expression I hope Mr Ro excuses me but
it forgives me you know they've had to
suffer this yeah the same as all
planning applications so can it not be
that at the very least that this
commuted sum is actually spent in the
denji the south of the district yeah we
can always argue it out afterwards if we
can't find land I mean there's a very
easy solution to this and this commuted
some and I'm more than happy to meet
with you to discuss it but I do think
chairman we should try and protect this
commuted sum for the south of the
district is that
possible two
minutes under that thank you
Mr clarify would that be for the
commuted sums for phase
one if this goes through so because
we've already agreed Comm sums for phase
two because all I'm getting at is that
you know if we do accept commute sums as
my colleague has just said you know
we're trying to do a lot of affordable
project projects and those projects some
of them may sit better I don't know in
another area of the district than just
completely closing down on the money for
just one particular location I'm not
objecting to it and if that's what you
want to do but I think you got to be
very careful if you're limiting the
projects to one area I believe I've got
20 seconds left of my two minutes
chairman can I can we say then that in
the first instance it goes to the south
of the district if that helps is it Mr
Johnson I mean
that that's not something that could
normally be delivered through the
planning mechanism in that sort of way
where there is a where there are sums
commuted that's that would be a decision
for the council to make I mean the
council the council will decide where
these monies go as appropriate through
the normal process of its delivery of of
its housing or any other form of
infrastructure that is where that
decision lies that cannot be something
subject to a condition or a clause in a
a section one6 thank you chairman thank
you and so I withdraw my
proposal thank you C councel
Thompson thank you chairman Mr SS could
you just do the microphone please thank
you sorry C th um it's obvious this
proposal is really unpopular but it it
does seem to me that it comes down to a
bold choice of do we refuse this
application leave the applicant with the
prospect of building Extra Care Home
that they can't find anyone to run and
we'll end up empty or do we accept that
we can have 40
40 small Flats mixture of one and two
bedroom Flats 20 of which will be market
and 20 affordable that seems to me to be
the only reasonable way ahead I don't
have to like it but the alternative
frankly doesn't bear thinking about
thank you thank you counc Thompson so
Council fluk you've withdrawn your
proposal I believe no what I was trying
to do is I was I've already got a
proposal on the table that we approve
the officer's recommendation we've dealt
with a bit about um the the decision
notice yeah
so all that's left really is was my
proposal in section 106 agreement that
it's specific as to where the money goes
now clearly Mr SS isn't comfortable
about that because it it feels as though
he's got other projects that might not
be in the south of of the of the of the
of the district so I think chairman if
if that can't be conditioned as such Mr
Johnson says it can't chairman then that
means I can't bring that forward that
proposal because it would obviously be
ultra vires yep so I withdraw that part
of the part of that proposal okay thank
you coun Matthew coun oh sorry councelor
Matthews than coun Matthews m Matthews
that's compliment not um thank you I
just I wanted to make um a couple of
points about Ring fencing commuted
summons for a particular area um that
that quite now I think as John S was
suggesting that quite limits how much
how the many can be used and obviously
that makes it if it is ring fence
certainly within the 106 um that makes
it more likely that the money won't ever
get spent you know um there is that
increased risk that that the those the
suitable projects won't come forward and
then then the money won't get spent um
and the other thing I was going to say
was oh yes just just um slightly off off
subject to a certain extent but um the
um just for members information that the
applicant has indicated that they will
be um willing to agree um a period of 20
years to spend the money from final
receipt of commuted sum which is longer
than would normally be um accepted so
normally 10 years as a standard but
they're willing to agree a much longer
period for the money to to be spent um
so that that reduces the risk of money
not being spent in or not being spent in
time challenge un legal challeng yeah
and um the other thing they've also said
is that they're they're happy for the
money to spend anywhere in the district
but um for projects that the the
district council thinks is the most
appropriate way of spending the money so
they're not putting any limit on where
the money is spent um and they're giving
us or suggesting that they'll give us um
give the council um quite um an extended
period to to spend the money which I
think it's important to to bear in mind
particularly based on some of the
concerns that have been raised thank you
thank you councelor benger please thank
you chair um it just seems to me again
it's a bit like a
a Russian doll this isn't it we won vote
for one thing and we're sold something
and then all of a sudden it all unpacks
and inside there's loads of other things
but what I don't understand is why can't
we have the affordable housing on site
can you just clarify why all the
affordable housing cannot be on
site you chairman the
um the on site now we're talking about
phase one as a whole and and including
this as well um the the the bottom line
is basically that there hasn't been a
register provider Housing Association
who said that they're willing to take on
any more than 20 on-site units on on
this on this development um and without
without them without any anyone coming
forward to take any more than 20 units
then um quite stuck and limited to to
how to take the forward unless the
council wants to try and take these
provision on um forward itself which
isn't certainly this number of units is
not really set up for doing that so um
based on the specialist advice of
housing that the offer that the
developer has been making is the best in
this in the circumstances is not ideal
and not what we prefer or choose I think
some some of the um other members have
expressed concerns but um it is
certainly the best that's on offer and
they they are they are please they are
um they're not trying to underprovided
unaffordable housing um but they're
they're they're they're in a in a
situation where they can't find a
provider and we've the council has tried
to help them find one and we still
haven't been able to find one and the
one that has expressed interest and he's
s sitting in the wings waiting to come
forward um said yes they would they
would take on a block of flats but only
20 and and beyond that their their their
interest um there is no interest so um
this seems to be the best compromise it
is compromised but the best off offer um
certainly at the moment and and in the
foreseeable future as know as often off
we can't see the situation changing OB
you haven't got Crystal Ball but um um
that's that's that's what our know our
professional view it is thank you thank
you councelor Morgan finally please uh
thank you through through you chair um I
know the the officer say there was a an
offer for this community sum to be over
20 years is that index
linked through shman the standard
Provisions would apply in 10 sixes which
yes which which do in think the commuted
Suns um as standing yeah makes rather so
counc s's W member and very quickly
final word thank you chair I do
appreciate that I I would hope that we
don't keep it for 20 years I I would
think that hopefully you're going to
have tough negotiations with the
developer and the commuted sums come
forward before and not after because we
all know there is a possibility of some
some sites going bankrupt and we're not
going to get anything so I'm I'm going
to speak about the elephant in the room
because I'm a realist and I think it's
important that this Council that we've
already in far as far as I'm concerned
we we shouldn't have approved it because
we didn't have the assisted care and we
didn't have the support from M County
Council who would have delivered it and
it wasn't policy compliant and that was
29 and there was only three members I
think who was here who attended that
meeting when that decision was made um
but what I'd say is can we be assured
that the officers work and are tough to
make sure that the provisions of these
sums if that's the way this Council
deems F fit is given earlier on in this
development because we all know it may
not happen because it's a risk to
anybody thank you thank you any comment
on that M
matth through you chairman the um the
triggers for the commu sum payments are
um that have been offered by the
applicant are set out in the papers in
the agenda um they they will be subject
to negotiation and I know that our
housing officers have expressed some
concerns about about the triggers and
whether they are they are right and in
in favor of the council um but they will
they will be uh discussed further and um
yes we share your concerns that want to
make sure that the payments are made um
at the right time but obviously you have
to take into account the the um
viability essentially of of of the
scheme as well so um and the developer
has to be when they're signing up to
these things they have to make sure that
they're they will be able to pay them
because obviously it's a it's a legal
agreement and um um yeah the consequence
is not not paying upon time obviously
they can um get get into into trouble
for that and and the other little point
I was going to make is just just to make
sure uh are aware that the affordable
housing onsite affordable housing
provision now being provided is not
Assisted Living Extra Care that's going
to be the mar Market housing so in terms
of ESS County council's objection to
Extra Care provision on this site
um back in
2018 in some ways this removes that
objection because it's it's it's it's
not assisted care living anymore for the
affordable housing on site it's it's
more um more General um or be it limited
to 55s and I thank you thank you
chairman can can I come back just
quickly very very very short yeah
because yeah I understand what Miss
Matthews has said but that that's you
know but the thing is I want to
reinforce that it is important that this
development delivers what it says it's
going to we've got so many developments
around burn them on Crouch and the next
uh plant application the one after the
section 106 they have done what it says
on the tin why why do why certain people
do what they say they're going to do in
developments and then others don't and
it seems to me as though it seems as
though we get a little bit of leeway and
I'm as a ward member and councilor fluka
knows how how passionate I'm about
Burnham we need to deliver what we say
and and I I feel a little bit assured
that you said we will do whatever we can
can and those delivery times we need to
do better than we try we need to do it
thank you for indulging me that's it
thank you very much indeed so members
after a very robust debate we had a
recommendation which we agreed with
councel Thompson to remove councel
Fluker put a recommendation in which
didn't stand because it wasn't sound so
we moved back to the original
recommendation to approve and I will
read it again um is it not I I I did
actually count I think the sequence was
and we certainly don't want to be debate
about this but councelor Thompson
withdrew her her recommendation there
was another recommendation which was
that was withdrawn and then I proposed
that we agree the officer's
recommendation and councelor
Morgan seconded it so that's where we
are so that's where we are I think
everybody would be really happy if you
put
it in a moment um so Tara you clear on
what we what we're
proposing the officer's recommendation
those for the officers cool
me get your T car there
t yeah um yeah um those in favor of the
officer's recommendation please
show all right so we got one two three
four five 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
for Tara those against please
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 seven against any
abstentions please I just myself to
abstain T please so that's carried
please Tara thank you very
much thank you members um and I do
understand that it is uh late and it is
um long debates but I think that they're
really important that everybody gets to
say what they need to say and that we
understand exactly what what we want for
the district item seven members which is
closely linked to item six so this is uh
reference
23233 MLA which is land Northwest of two
molden Road burnam on Crouch it's found
on pages 93 to 106 of your agenda's
paper and there is a members update and
again Miss Matthews would you please
present the
report thank you thank you thank you
chairman um yeah so this is on the same
address albeit this is the whole of
phase one um which we've been talking
about on on previous agenda item so this
there an application to modify the 106
agreement um associated with the outline
plan permission for phase one um and
they seek the applicant is seeking to
amend the obligations relating to
affordable housing um so the site is
outside settlement boundary Burham again
that um and forms phase one of the
approved development known as burn and
Waters construction is underway um and
got phases two and three which have
beyond the northern and Eastern
boundaries of phase one which um do both
have planning
permission um so alongside the current
application which was subject to the
previous agenda item A variation to the
affordable housing obligations which
form part of the section 106 associated
with the existing outline plan
permission for phase one is sought to
reded A variation phase one um the
current affordable housing contribution
is a 30% provision which is 50 Assisted
Living Extra Care units and um now as
we've um discussed and explained um as
offices um a proceeding item it hasn't
been possible to find a register
provider to take on these units so an
alternative um provision is being
proposed so location plan not a very
good location plan apologies for that
but um that's the approved
layout these were on the previous um
presentation
um so these are the Assisted Living
units here these three blocks here
okay right so
the the there's there's possible
Alternatives that are being offered the
the applicant
is basically willing to um any any of
the any of the Alternatives they they're
they're basically saying well we're
making this offer these offers and the
council can basically choose which one
which one they prefer and part we partly
tied up with the legal process and which
one is
easier and cleaner and less complicated
um to uh secure um so the the one one
option is that if plan permission is
granted for the 40 residential units for
phase one which the resolution has now
been made to approve that um there's an
offer of on-site provision of eight of
these 40 extra units um and a commuted
sum around 5 million PS being paid to
equivalent to the balance for phase one
which would be 42 um 42 of the approved
Assisted Living Extra Care units um the
financial contribution to be paid in
installments and the amounts of timings
are yet yet to be finalized as I um
alluded to on the previous agenda item
um there was an offer a suggestion if
plan permission was going to be refused
for the 40 units but um we can perhaps
move on from that because the resolution
is now being made in a positive way so
the other option is for if plan
permission is approved for the
additional 40 units from which
resolution has now been made so there
could be an on-site provision of 20
units 20 of these 40 units and a
commuted Su being paid for the
equivalent balance of 30 of the approved
Assisted Living care units um and the
afford in which case the affordable
housing contribution required for the
additional 40 units would then be
commuted some but on the basis that that
um yeah so does does the option
of that that slot in application the 40
extra units either being completely a
commuted some or partially computed some
um the alternative agreed will be
secured through the variation of the
section 106 um through aeda
modification and um I've just going to
point out I mean it's already been
mentioned but there is a letter support
from chela Housing partnership in case
they will be prepared to take on the
alternative on-site affordable housing
units proposed that's that a block of 20
um units um hopefully in conjunction
with the report that that that makes
sense but I'm obviously happy to take
any any uh questions that members have
thank you thank you councelor white
please my apologies we actually have a
public speaker registered I'm sorry
again it's uh Mr
roow could speak on this
one and again Mr swords Mr gayer if you
need to to join the debate please
do okay Mr Ro I think you know how to go
Mr row thank you hello again Mr chairman
members thank you for allowing me to
speak again um as you know I'm Stuart Ro
the panning director at burn and wers
limited and also um the planning design
Bureau um I'm pleased that the committee
resolved to approve the proceeding
application uh meaning that 204 homes
will be built on site um chela Housing
Partnership have uh the board approval
to purchase the units um I can say that
because there's a letter coming in the
application so it's in the public domain
um perhaps the simplest way of looking
at the affordable housing numbers um is
that in combination phase one approved
166 dwellings and the preceding
application that's just been resolved to
be approved was 40 so 206 in total 30%
which is a policy compliant uh
affordable housing provision of 206 is
62 units 20 we will build on site
remaining 42 units we would like to make
a developer contribution it gets very
complicated as to how you split that up
and I'll be honest with you we don't
mind that burnning Waters it can be
whatever approach that the council's
legal advisors think is most appropriate
as long as our legal advisors agree then
that's fine um so what I hope is that
the council can agree that it is the
best way forward that we provide a
contribution for 42 units equivalent to
that you can use that for whatever
purposes you best deemed fit in the
district for affordable housing
provision and we it has no issue for us
whether it's sort of 5 years or 20 years
when the money's gone it's gone as far
as we're concerned it's left uh and
delivered and you do the best that you
can for your residents um with that and
how you decide to do that as far as
we're concerned is the council's
business so um all I want to sort of do
is to commend the report to you and um
thank you for your time thank you very
much indeed thank
you
councilor white please thank you thank
you Mr chairman actually this ties in
nicely with the question I wanted with
the last one um because these commuted
sums they're fantastic molden District
Council has probably had commuted sums
for the last five years um how many
houses have we actually supplied under
those commuted
sums um the and that's the first
question and the second one is I don't
want any commuted sums I want these
housing built I don't want any committed
sums at all so I I mean is there a way
we can condition it so they have to be
provided rather than money because money
goes it just I don't know it gets
consultations and reports and everything
else if if we've got to have this
housing let's have this housing and and
I'd like it tied up so this section 106
agreement somehow is worded so that yes
it's tied to the current applicants but
it also in perpetuity goes on to whoever
owns the site the land or purchases it
because that's why I wanted an fbia
because I'm concerned that as no houses
have been sold there are May well be
some viability issues um but say can it
be done I'm I'm really surprised the
legal officer isn't here to go through
this tonight because this is the most
important part and yes I do get cross
with this because we never see the
affordable housing and we need it
particularly older persons affordable
housing so I I I want an option where
they have to build it it's compulsory on
on gaining the permission
question was a question mat Mr Gay would
you like to take that thank you just in
relation to um affordable housing that's
been delivered using previous commuted
sums um members may recall um the Steven
house purchase which is going through so
potentially that's for two bed units uh
with the potential for a bedet unit to
be factored in now that um I would say
over 34s of that funding is coming from
the commuted sums that we've been given
historically um in terms of future use
of commuted sus well obviously that's
where the housing projects come in they
could take a range of forms they could
be for the purposes of trying to bring
back empty homes they could be land
projects they could be purchase direct
purchase of dwellings there's a whole
range of there's a whole range of
projects that can be considered MH and
that's why it's it's also impossible for
me to say that will deliver five
properties that will deliver two uh some
of these projects have some very uh big
possibilities other projects would be
more specific and local um such as for
example Steven's house or Edmunds and
tensing's potential um purchases um and
and also um in terms of working with
housing providers as well um sometimes
we have to consider what the registered
providers are saying and if they say you
know we can only we only want so many
units in in an area then we have to try
and take that on board and we have to
try and work with them to to to get the
best um the best out of it that's the
situation so hopefully that answers the
questions but happy to answer anymore
very very amicable thank you very much
indeed Mr G councilor Morgan please uh
yes thank you chair just to to help out
Council white in the absence of the
monitoring officer um I'm not aware of
any legal ability to actually force a
developer to complete a development if
it doesn't want to that's it's an
interesting idea perhaps we might
suggest with the law commission but
moving on to the actual can some can the
officer just please um explain to me I
noticed that there are two options here
in this variation how are we going to
decide which one is going to be the one
to give with thank you
through through your chairman um one of
the options that's on there uh no longer
applies because it's in the event that
um the previous agenda item was
um was um the resolution was to refuse
the previous agenda item um so the first
option um one of the options Falls away
um so we're just left with the one
option that officers are recommending
um well there left one option that has
been proposed but the the the the
recommendation is is is to allow um an
option again this is to give flexibility
and certainly legally um about whether
to give and to give yeah to give the
council the um the option so legally um
it can choose between the two um without
needing to come back to committee but if
if there's one option that that members
want to not agree to then then obviously
with their um gift to to be able to do
that but the the options are
basically
um depend on how many of
the that block of 20 we talked about in
in the previous application how many of
those are going to be um instead of the
50 that have been approved so we've got
an option of eight of them with a
commuted sum or 20 of them and a
commuted sum um and that will tie in
with the other options that were um in
the previous recommendation so um it's
not ideal that officers are recommending
options but it is purely intended to
give the our legal team the flexibility
of going for the one that fits best
legally and um is the simplest and
straightforward um in terms of actually
what happens on the ground it would be
the same because you'd have a block of
20 affordable units on site provision
and the rest of the affordable housing
for the extended phase one um I think
reference was made to 206 dwellings
would be would be the uh would be a
commuted sum so the result would be the
same but the the either or is is is in
there to give the flexibility to to do
to be able to do the one that's easiest
and and legally sound um and more
straightforward yeah thank you okay just
before we come to C spensive probably
not what we want is the easiest we
probably want the best um easiest in
terms of Legally and um so it would be
the the best in another word I could
have used but one one that um is uh
secures it
more directly yeah we we just want to
make sure that we get the very best
outcomes the very best options get no
the more the the more worthy illegal
agreement becomes the the more um more
difficult I know with it's open to
ration isn't it so if if it can be more
straightforward in black and
whiteed we then there will be no ground
for any sisters or anyone in the future
to to pick it apart thank you um just
before I come to council spenley um Mr
GRE Daman did you want to
speak do you raise your hand sorry my
apologies um I just wanted to to stress
um housing have made a a recommendation
under Point 34 of our our um supporting
document which states what we feel is is
the the best option um like I said we've
got a um RP that's in final stages of
negotiation 420 if all of a sudden we're
given additional units we don't have a
mechanism for disposal of that and
there's no RPS that are waiting the
wings to pick that up and effectively
that could become then you know empty
dwellings which we don't want to do so
that's why we've we've made our
recommendations at 34 uh because we feel
that that offers the best um value for
money and also opportunities for further
housing thank you thank you very much
Council Paula spenley please thank you
chair so I'm just going to go back to
something that councilor stamp said when
she was worried that some of us were
being a bit quiet well some of the newer
members in this room could be forgiven
for thinking what a mess what an
absolute mess and actually the truth is
we're all sitting here and we're over a
barrel I don't want to see commuted sums
because without being disrespectful for
any to anyone or saying anything that
was in PNC we all know how successful
that can be don't we the use of those
commuted sums so I I'm sorry to say I
feel a sense of absolute despair sitting
here and what I I just want to say
something that's constructive yes we
need the best possible solution and
please please can we as a council work
to not make mistakes like this again
thank you thank you cast stamp yeah
thank you Mr chair thank you councelor
spenley I appreciate those comments
because it is actually a mind I mean
I've actually had and I'd like to I
wanted to thank the officers um on the
previous previous application who has
met with some of us to find out and get
to the nigr with other members about the
way this planning application was worded
and the section I was get it wrong 73 37
96 whatever it is so Bingo yeah so I'd
like to thank everybody for doing that
because um it is very very difficult and
I would advise the newer members if
you've ever got any queries the ask the
officers because it is very very
difficult I mean I've followed this
application from before 2019 when it
came up I've got a biggest pile of
papers this is a fraction of what I've
got at home with everything that's gone
on but anyway Mr chair what I'd like to
say is when do we invisage I'm looking
at option one and it says based on the
potential commuted sum of around 5
million the applicant has suggested
installments of 1 million prior to the
occupation of 50% of the market houses
within phase one do we have a estimated
time frame for that and for the second
one 2 million prior to the occupation of
60% of the market houses within phase
one etc etc and the next question Miss
Matthews you be you'll be pleased to
know it is a question are those
percentages normal to this Authority as
in percentage of delivery rates for
houses or are we being lenient uh to uh
this specific um
development thank you thank you m
Matthews uh thank you chairman um I'm
just looking back at my emails on this
because it was a question I asked the
agent about in terms
of
um anticipated times of
delivery
um I think prob might not be able to
find it because there've been quite a
few
um I know the the um from memory I can I
know that the the existing 106 requires
the um affordable housing to be provided
before the occupation of the 65th
dwelling I think um and that was
anticipated to be June this
year um to give you some idea but in
terms of future buildout rates I don't I
don't have that information to hand but
um in terms of when the first payment
might land um in our our account then
that might give you some idea of when
that might be so quite soon potentially
but in and in terms of in terms of
delivery rates um again I don't know
whether that's that's normal rates
obviously that will vary depending on
the type of development obviously it's
quite specialist and the part of the
district um but so I'm sorry I can't
answer that question okay M final
question ccor stand please you know it's
now just gone straight out my oh yes can
I just make a suggestion in future
because um when you say 50% or something
of something it could be of a really
minute number I personally would find it
extremely helpful if it had a number
rather than a percentage because
otherwise you've got to sit I would have
to go back and forgive me Members I
haven't gone back I've had enough spent
enough time on this to actually work it
out otherwise I'd have provided it with
you but I think it would help members to
know exactly at what number of house
that would be I can always remember the
police saying to me councelor St we've
doubled the community police in the
district for you I said how many of you
got already he said one and that was
many years ago when we thought about
trying to get better policeing in this
area so I'm always a little bit
skeptical when people want to put
percentages rather than figures that's
just noted isn't it so so members we we
actually have a recommendation um within
the report the recommendation is through
agree A variation of section 106 s106
agreement with Associated plan and
permission
18443 out as set out in Section 8 do I
have a second there councelor fluka
members can I those in favor please
raise your
hands one two three four five 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 and yourself 17 I
think was it
16 including 16 including you 16 for
thank you those against
please one 2 three four five
six
7 7 we just double check that one seven
seven yeah that's seven against please
Tara any exstension please just myself
Tara so that's carried which is agenda
right at seven thank you very much
indeed again members for a robust and
very careful debate uh we move on to
agenda item 8
um which is uh application
23500 fulm this is land bounded by mm
Road and creeky lame Bon Crouch which is
fade which is found on pages 107 to 152
of your pack and members they have an
update that was circulated earlier uh uh
Miss brle I can't hear you can you not
it's far too much because I've got me
head down reading the was the wind
whistling I apologize I had a late
dinner absolutely thanks m Matthews no y
absolutely just bear with us members
just by um Miss Matthews um leaves the
chamber thank you so much for all your
help as well thank
you
right
nice
cappuccino so Miss Matthews exit the
chamber at 9:40 thanks cther that's
right thank you okay I'll just
reintroduce the item members um speaking
a little bit louder can you hear me at
the back yeah okay says agenda item 8
235s m land bounded by molden Road and
cxy Lane burnam on Crouch found on page
107 to 152 there was a m mbers a members
update uh circulated earlier on today a
presenter is Miss Bradley please present
the
report thank you thank you chair good
evening
members this is a full planning
application for the erection of 37
dwellings including 13 affordable
dwellings together with public open
space landscaping and Associated works
and infrastructure including vehicular
access pedestrian links and drainage
infrastructure look at the site location
plan the application site is located to
the south of molden Road and to the east
of creeky Lane um and it's 2.9 hect an
area the site includes two Parcels of
land parcel one is land to the north and
is 1.4 hectares in area and parcel 2 is
the land to the South and is 1 09
hectares in area they're connected by
Endeavor way um which is the the the red
line connecting them um the dwelling
known as Creek seed Lodge is located
between the two
Parcels um in terms of context I think
it's just useful to to give you a little
bit of background to this because it is
is relevant to the application so the
application site is located outside the
settlement boundary which you can see
outlined in in black um however it forms
part of the Strategic allocation which
is
s2i and is therefore part of the land
west of B burnam on Crouch strategic
allocation which plans for 180
dwellings now the application site
benefits from extent planning permission
which is this permission
here um sorry the site here
and that was granted in August of
2017 that established the principal for
residential development on the land um
to provide 180 new dwellings including
70 affordable dwellings and all
Associated dwell um pris development
including access onto molden Road open
space the spine Road um and other
relevant
infrastructure The Proposal also
included outline provision for a 50 to
60 bid Care Home a nursery 3.4 hectar of
commercial uses and 65 hectares of
allotments so that was that one moving
on in 2018 we had a variation to the
full planning permission which was
granted through a section 73
application and that approved a more
logical layout for 174 dwellings um and
also simplified the road hierarchy now
the site subject of that application
that variation application was not in
included in that application and it's
it's the land and gray that we're
looking at there so that wasn't included
in the
variation um then we had another
application um in December of
2020 it was granted on appeal for the
development of an additional 36 units
including 14 dwell ings so that was
areas
of less developed land within the site
that had additional homes um now built
on them and as I said that was granted
at
appeal so looking at the proposed master
plan or or layout plan um we have 11
Market dwellings proposed in parcel one
so that's the one to the north with two
new vehicular accessways from from
molden Road um I'll come on to it in a
bit more detail molden Road um which
would serve eight dwellings and from
creeky Lane which would serve three
dwellings the dwellings are all two
stories in height and are detached and
served by double garages or in the case
of plot nine a triple garage and they
also have car parking spaces to the
front density is low at 7.9 dwellings
per
hectare
the southern part parcel One features um
sorry the southern part of parcel one
and I'll just move on to that now so
you've got a bit more detail features an
attenuation Basin public open space and
a pedestrian footway that links to
Endeavor way
here so moving on to parcel two um the
26 dwellings proposed in parcel 2
comprise 13 Market dwellings and 13
affordable dwellings density is
approximately 20 dwellings per hectare
but with an overall sight density of
about 15 dwellings per
hectare now we've got a public right of
way that runs in this direction here so
from
the
northeast of the site running sorry
southeast of the site running up to the
northeast of the site adjacent to creeky
Lane in this location um so it
terminates up up in the the northwest
corner and the northern corner of the
parcel comprises the the open space and
pedestrian links to the footway as as
well veicular access would be from
Endeavor way um this Spur Road to the
north of the parcel and also this
existing Road here which is mman
drive just moving on quickly to housing
mix we've got the 11 Market units in
parel one are all um five beard houses
now it was this is replacing the the
extent planning permission where where
there was planning permission there was
for um six Market homes in this location
so it's a slightly higher density here
um than what was proposed but as I said
before still quite a low density um o
overall and um parcel two includes a mix
of dwellings including one and three bed
Bungalows and also houses with between
one and four
bedrooms in terms of affordable housing
the 13 affordable housing units include
nine affordable rented units and four
shared ownership homes as
shown now just to touch on um affordable
housing here it's noted that the
affordable provision is less than the
policy provision um of
40% however this is due to an
over-provision previously by the
applicant on The Wider site um is that
resulted
in an over provision of 2.4 homes um so
what we've got now is just over 40%
overall which is considered
acceptable um I've got the the housing
types set out here um as you can see it
includes two one bed bungalows um in
terms of affordable rented and also
three three bed houses in the affordable
rented which are much needed um in in
this district and in this
location so just moving on
to sorry I keep getting confused because
the mouth doesn't control my laptop um
so I I keep thinking I'm doing something
and I'm actually not um so moving on to
um passel one in terms of landscaping
and public open space so most of the
existing hedges around parel one
adjacent to molden Road and ceky Lane
would be retained however there are
areas that would need to be removed to
provide for the
accesses um public open space as I said
earlier is provided in in the southern
part of this parcel and it includes an
existing Pond and an attenuation Basin
now it's noted that there are concerns
from Neighbors regarding flooding um the
lead local flood Authority has been
consulted and also been made aware of
the most recent objection from the
neighbors however no objections have
been raised subject to conditions which
include surveying the existing pipe work
to check for
blockages now this is where I must
apologize to members because I realized
in my report I didn't include the most
upto-date response from the llfa and I
do apologize for that and I apologize
that it wasn't in the members update
either what's proposed here is to
replace condition nine which requires a
maintenance plan for the subs sud scheme
to be
submitted um however those details are
already contained in the submitted flood
risk assessment so the llfa is content
that that condition isn't necessary um
however what they have conditioned is a
condition about the checking the pipe
Works basically so it would be that the
development hereby permitted shall not
be commenced until the existing pipes
within the extent of the site which will
be used to convey surface water are
cleared of any blockage and are restored
to a fully working condition so should
members decide to Grant permission for
this application I would ask that this
condition replace the condition nine in
the report for
that so moving on to parcel two um again
we've got pedestrian linkages provided
to the public right of way through the
public open space that's provided within
the northern part of the parcel um the
public open space includes a community
orchard wildf flower areas and a
grassland moving now to building Heights
um building Heights show all the
buildings all the dwellings sorry in
parcel one uh twostory dwellings in
height with single story garages um and
in parcel two there's a mix of Bungalows
with two story dwellings um as you'll
have seen in the report we have
recommended um permitted development
rights be removed for that parcel one to
ensure the the buildings the dwellings
don't get bulkier and with um additions
of Roof Dormers and that sort of thing
in time to
come now because we've got a lot of
house types with this application I
haven't included all of the elevations
here so don't worry I'm not going to go
through um 15 or so slides now of
elevations and floor plans but what I've
just done is is select a sample so that
you can see the a variety of house types
that are proposed on the site so we
we've got um within parel two this is an
example of a three bed
dwelling um this is an example of the
bungalows in um parcel 2
and again we're looking in parcel two
this would be one of the affordable
housing a two bed house and then we've
got an example of the larger five beard
dwellings that would be in parcel one um
and also the the garages that would be
proposed we've got the single double and
the one triple garage that's proposed
and again just to give you an idea of
how this would look on the site I've
included the um Street Scenes that have
been included so the first one is a
street scene of of molden road so that
up here in Gray we've got the existing
um development here we've got the two
gate houses that haven't been built um
to date with Endeavor way here and then
carrying on along here is the proposed
development here with the proposed
access from molden Road in this
location we've got another one on Creek
SE Lane um with the proposed access
would be here so this is molden Road and
coming down Creek SE Lane this is what
you'd see with the open space um in this
location and then the final Street Scene
is in parcel 2 along the north so this
shows the existing development here
across endeav way to the Bungalows and
then up to the twostory dwellings again
it's just to give you a flavor of what's
proposed so looking now to to the um the
photos of the site the first one is
looking Northwest from the junction of
Anda Lane um and molden road so looking
towards parcel one and then we're
looking back the other way now A View
From molden Road looking Southeast
towards the junction with creeky Lane
and the site
Beyond this is a view again we've just
moved F further towards the site so the
junction of creeky Lane and molden Road
looking towards parel one behind the
Hedge this is a view from creeky Lane
looking along the public right of way so
we're basically looking into parcel two
um through the the the vegetation
here this photo is looking Northeast
across parel one from Creek sea Lane and
it's taken from adjacent to the exis of
Creek sea Lodge which was the dwelling I
mentioned before which is in between
parcel one and parcel
two so moving into the um existing
development now what we're looking at
here is the the junction of endeavor way
which heads down to the right hand side
and new Drive which is to the left so
we're looking Northeast across parel
to this is now looking along North along
and D way with Newman drive on the left
hand side of the photo looking across
parel two again um with the ex in
development on the right hand side of
the
photo this is looking along the public
right of way um from endea way towards
creeky Lane so again we've got the um
parcel two on the left hand side
here um this is another one on Endeavor
way looking with the parel two to the
left hand side and existing development
to the
right again and Dev way now this is
looking back towards the existing
development um where you can see just to
the left hand side of back there the
Bungalows on Newman
Drive another one this is a view from in
front of the Bungalows on human Drive
looking towards the existing development
of in div
way um again looking in a similar
Direction it's almost the same photo I
think um and then another one on
Endeavor way looking with the existing
development on the right hand side
towards parel one on the left hand side
of the photo I think that's the end of
my
photos um so just wanting to sort of
summarize my my report really and and
the the recommendation here um the site
is within the allocation a strategic
cocation for 180 dwellings um as you'll
have read in the report The Proposal
provides for an uplift in dwelling
numbers over 180 dwellings um and given
the additional dwellings that have
already been permitted um it would take
it to 200 147 dwellings however it is
considered that the necessary
infrastructure can be provided through
financial contributions under a section
106 agreement which would cover
Financial contributions towards the NHS
education libraries um the Rams payment
and also on-site provision thankfully of
affordable
housing the density and design is
considered to be acceptable and in
keeping with the character and
appearance of the area the development
will be cohesive a cohesive part of the
existing development due to the use of
many of the same house types and
materials there is on-site provision for
13 affordable dwellings however as I
mentioned earlier um because there was
an a credit of 2.4 affordable homes on
the previous
application this application would
deliver slightly below the 40% but it
essentially evens out sitewide at 41.6
2% so it would be policy
compliant and also a benefit of this
application is the inclusion of three
three bed dwellings and two one bed
Bungalows for affordable rent and this
provision is welcomed certainly by our
housing
colleagues the highways Authority has
raised no objection subject to
conditions likewise the lead local flood
Authority has no objection subject to
conditions including the revised one I
mentioned earlier um furthermore no
objections are raised in regard to
impacts on ecology trees and
archaeology there are no objections from
other statutary consulties subject to
planning
obligations so taking that into account
the applications recommended for
approval subject to a section 106
agreement and conditions thank you thank
you m BR very very good report um we
have public speakers listed here um is
Miss hindle here miss hendle um again
you saw early on if you can make your
way up to the
the the the table and somebody I'm
sure will allow you to come
in so miss Hindu as the agent again um
once you start talking the the clock
will start and you have two
minutes thank you chair good evening
members my name is Libby hindle I'm
planning manager at Barrett David Wilson
homes based in Chelmsford we're a
developer that Prides ourselves on
quality to creating great places that
contri contribute to the local community
where people wish to live we are the
only National house Builder to have won
hbfs five-star award for customer
satisfaction for 14 consecutive years
this is Testament to our delivery of
high quality energy efficient homes and
placemaking such as that already
delivered at Corinthian
place the parcels of land that this
application relates are within the
Strategic site allocation for a minimum
of 180 dwellings and both benefit from
ex examp permission for residential
development the proposals which have
been directly informed by extensive
pre-application discussions including
with the Town Council are designed to in
to form a seamless part of the existing
Corinthian Place development and will
complete the attractive Frontage at this
key Gateway location at burnman
Crouch with the full support of
council's housing officer it will
provide the desired mix of homes to
address greatest local need including
three bed hous for affordable rent the
mix also addresses the needs for older
persons and those with disabilities
through the provision of seven Bungalows
which are wheelchair adaptable we can
confirm our commitment to immediate
delivery should planning be granted
today the low density of the development
ensures proper sized Gardens for
families appropriate parking and more
green space for the wider Community to
enjoy an opportunities to enhance
habitats and biodiversity by
incorporating various SS features the
development will provide better
which the llfa acknowledge and have
raised no objection the proposals meet
the required space standards and will
deliver dwellings to high specification
that maximizes Energy Efficiency members
are therefore respectfully requested to
approve this application through
enabling the delivery of high quality
homes at this allocated site thank you
thank you m thank you and do we also
have um Miss Susan Middleton is any
other speakers or is that a typo yeah no
chairman that was my error that was for
the previous application okay sry thank
you sorry no that's all right I just
want to make sure
there so um members we have a
recommendation to approve subject to the
conditions as detailed in Section 8 of
the report councelor white please and
then councelor Fluker thank you Mr
chairman sorry I've spok on every single
one this time but um the first one is
under
5.7.2 under policy S6 of the ldp it's
says we should have safe pedestrian
cycle and Bridal ways and I seem to
remember when we start this application
councelor Hall and I argued to get a
bridal on this application but it seems
to have disappeared um so you know
what's happened to these to the to the
bridal ways um and we got 5.6.5 is a
wildlife Corridor 5.6.7 is a woodland
Corridor and the community Orchard which
I do support and if they need their
apple juice turned in their apples
turned into juice I can do that for them
for for the community so that's not a
problem um but um where are the bridal
ways you because we we keep being told
this is going to be in every single
application and yet I've yet to see one
where it's actually in there um the next
thing is under climate change under
5.7.1 5 I'm really pleased to see the
car chain charges but where are the
solar panels I mean why aren't they
compulsory for every single new build
why can't we mold District Council try
and become the greenest Authority why
can't we say as a criteria we want solar
panels in every single house I'm pleased
to see the car charger but I mean it
doesn't only help the climate it helps
the people living there with cheaper
bills and the Developers for them to put
the um solar panels on at bills stage is
not that much so that that I'm really
disappointed with and I don't know if
there's anything we can do on this one
it's probably too late but it's
something I'd like to see Incorporated
going forwards um and the last one is
under 5.10 it's sort of generalized
under ecology it says we should have a
new we should under the nppf and the ldp
have a biodiversity net gain um and
although it says it has it will have
significant harm on nature and we can
condition it I I couldn't find any
figures for what that net gain was so
perhaps officers could assist um so
there they're the things that the three
points I'd like to raise thank you thank
you um thank you um in terms of bridal
ways there aren't any Bridal ways that
are proposed in this application so I
can confirm that um the second point
about solar panels um they aren't
included but sorry they are included
what I haven't done is conditioned that
so we we could could through a condition
um ensure that solar panels are provid
did no that's a good one I should have
raised it the last application you
agreement with that we wouldn't we we
subject to agreement we we could require
that solar panels are
provided um yep I think
that's reading apologies there there
there is reference to solar panels in
the application but I I didn't
include um so we we could look at doing
that if if if members are agreeable and
the third point about biodiversity net
gain I can't remember off the top of my
head I'm afraid um great Christen nutes
ended up taking president with with
ecology and we um we got a bit carried
away trying to sort them out so I'm not
able to give you the figure I'm afraid
for biodiversity Net game but that it
has been provided in this application
I'm I just can't give you the figure I'm
sorry thank you okay councelor fluka
you're next on the list yeah thank you
chairman I I really don't know where to
start on this one but um obviously this
is a strategic allocated site so you
know it's within the local development
plan I councelor white spoke to charging
points and uh and I'm sure she's
forgotten but the uh parking standards
dpd actually says that all of the new
builds now have to have air and electric
charging point and the four cours uh
which is something which was slightly
overlooked um I mean I think most most
members certainly in the south of the
district are very conversant with the
David Wilson barretts or the barretts
David Wilson pallet of houses um I mean
in my own world there there's two
developments there both Gateway
developments to the village and it's as
good as it gets when it comes to new
developments so chairman i' I I would go
to uh paragraph one of the report and
propose chairman that we agree the
officer's recommendation with the at
that the houses do have solar panels and
I don't think there'll be any issues
with that because I understand that
Barrett David Wilson homes include them
anyway chairman that's my
proposal is that second Council white
second that that's with the replacement
of condition nine as Bradley said
earlier on thank you very much councelor
stamp please yeah chairman I'd like to
declare an interest at risk of another
member of our group being reported to
the standards or the monitoring officer
so uh cuz it seems to be the flavor of
the month to to pick on us at the moment
so what I'd like to actually draw to
every's attention is if I'm allowed to
speak on this because obviously I live
very close to this site um but I uh
there's a couple of points I'd like to
raise um and that is I am total in
agreement don't faint um with most of
this um because they are and I agree
with councelor fluka I've had um
conversations with Ry and his team over
many years and they've always always
listened but this time he didn't so I'm
he's in for a bit of a telling off I
actually did ask him if he could not
have the access route on creeky Lane
that access on creeky Lane is dangerous
you've got the you've got the triangle
there you've got the hedges that
overgrow it's very difficult and just
outside the garage Mr chair you do you
mind just outside the the um garage
there is a 4.8 M that's all it is the
road to get people passing and when you
edge out of what you would do and the
other ax entrance is on the molden road
which is a little bit further down and
they've got a huge entrance on Endeavor
way because it's literally outside my
kitchen window and it actually works
really well so I'm a little bit
disappointed but chairman I won't vote
on this and I'm sorry to let my
residents down but because of the
reasons I've given I don't want to be I
must probably put before standards for
the other application anyway uh but I
don't particularly want to be put before
standards on this application
but I want to emphasize about the um
flooding on that house uh and I know Ry
has spoken to the home home older and
householder home older uh and can we
please make sure that that is sorted
because it is flooding from the Gateway
homes on land that is going to be
developed and it is important we know I
walk used to walk my dog run those
fields all the time before it was
developed and we know how muddy and SOG
it is so based on that uh and I'd like
to congratulate Ray and his team because
they've actually helped to deliver other
infrastru infrastructure projects in my
dist my area which is very rare that we
get any infrastructure out where I am
but I'd like to thank him um and thank
you chair okay thank you very much
councelor spenley counc Paul spenley
please thank you chair um no need for me
to comment now because I was going to
make the point with regard to Creek SE
Lane because of stuff that I the Council
stamps already covered thank report
thank you councelor Morgan yeah thank
you chair um uh just
sitting as I do on the Strategic housing
board I'm aware that there is a acute
shortage of three bedroom affordable
rented accommodation of the district uh
and so I was just wondering through you
chair whether the housing department had
any say or or or in the actual Mex is or
whether they that that amount of three
bedrooms can be can be improved thank
you Mr swords Mr
Gayla getting your steps
up
you put your microphone on Mr swords
thank you yeah originally when we had
the uh prea discussions with the
developer um it wasn't what we're seeing
now so they have worked with us they've
listened with us and they have provided
the three three beds and the two bed uh
the two Bungalows which is you know
great news for the Strategic housing
department um in terms of anything more
than that the difficulty we would have
there is
if you increase on one you lose on
another so I'm just pleased that we've
got that mix from them on on the two one
beds Bungalows and the three three bed
houses you know it could have gone the
other way they could have had a three
bed house for an intermediate product we
need it for the rented so I've got three
of them there which is fantastic for
us if you're if you're happy Mr swords
and so am I thank you um councelor Bill
thank you Mr
swords thank you Mr chairman just really
wanted to follow on what from what canc
stamp has said about the flooding it's
not just this particular resident house
that is flooding the bottom there's a
bridge at the bottom of Creek sea Lane
and that is flooding to the extent that
it is
impossible and this is again it's a
result of this development
because ccer stamps doing I'm not quite
sure it's got worse it happened before
the development but it's got much much
much worse since the development that
we've already got we're going to get
more of these rain events or whatever we
call them as you know we we experience
the effects of climate change so
um I suppose what I'm asking really is
it just that the developer be mindful of
the impact on the environment of the
development and that as much mitigation
can be sought as possible I don't know
whether we can condition that or if
there's anything we can do about that
but there are properties at the bottom
of creeky that are being cut off and
should we need you know emergency
vehicles Etc I need to access them they
wouldn't be able to so it's it is a very
real danger thank you thank you very
much indeed finally councelor fluka yeah
thank you chairman for fear doing the
officer's job I mean um there are no
objections from highways I I know that
Junction well in Creek SE Lane um if
Highway say it's okay then we just sadly
have to accept that um with regards to
the uh local flood Authority I just ask
members to look at
5.99 um where it says overall The
Proposal is considered acceptable and
there are additional conditions chairman
so uh you know my proposal has been made
and seconded thank you and support the
members I put that proposal those in
favor there one I think we
can by asent members I think that's
clear any desent
any
abstention I just clarify is that with
the caveat about the solar panels yes
absolutely absolutely 100% thank you
very much indeed there was one um
exstension as well please um number nine
is any other business that I deem is
urgent I have absolutely none uh we
close the meeting members uh at 10:14
and thank you so much for to help and
travel
[Music]
safely